e
I think we're about ready to get started
um we have a clerk so that's uh the most
important role um so I'd like to ask uh
everyone just uh stand and maybe we'll
start with the Pledge of
Allegiance uh representative dry sure I
pledge Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation
God indivisible with liy and justice for
all thank you very much uh everybody um
with the uh snow and delays and uh
school closings um uh getting started a
little bit late um and we have a number
of people absent uh today because of the
weather
um um we have new bills um I think we're
um um thank you for that input um uh
just note also for future reference um
uh we did get our third um and final I
believe cell phone bill um so I will be
um establishing a subcommittee to take a
look at um those bills and we have a
number of bills also on the subject of
buling and um I'll schedule a full
committee work session um one day um
probably the week after next um to talk
about
bullying
um and with that I think we can start
with our first bill of the day Mr cheer
yes I I I see questioning looks around
and I just want to clear we we don't
need a quorum when we're just hearing
bills correct correct yes correct yes um
uh we we like to have a a full committee
um with substitutes if necessary when we
um vote on bills but hearings um very
often things like today happen or you
know we have to leave to go to another
committee things like that so um as long
as um there's someone here to open the
hearing we're uh good to
go so we'll start with the first build
of the day and I'll turn the gavl over
dry yes while um chairman quelli is
going to the mic uh I just wanted to
remind folks we weren't here yesterday
but yesterday was chrisal mlli
anniversary day and Celebration Day and
uh was marked here initially in 2019
that photo is the wall behind us so I
thought it' be nice to just bring that
you all right I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill 121 and recognize
sponsor thank you very much Madam chair
um this bill um establishes local uh
special education advisory councils we
have a state advisory Council referred
to a Sac that we've had legislation the
last uh couple of sessions on but this
is a a local um advisory Council and the
intent that this is to be uh parent
driven councils um with
um parents of special needs children in
the district um and I I think it's
important that it's parent driven it's
not a
district um a district organization per
se it's it's a parent
organization um to uh look at uh special
needs in the district and just walk you
through um the bill a couple of points
um to begin with um and I I'll just
mention that um this is the result of U
discussions I've had with uh special
education
Advocates so um that's the Genesis of
the
bill um the um Roman two on the first
page uh describes the makeup of the
council um and again it's uh app parents
um in the uh district and if there are
multiple towns in the district um there
needs to be at least one parent from
each Town um in the
council um the meetings should be open
to all uh parents with uh children with
disabilities and you'll see enrollment
for the duties of the uh Council um one
to advise the districts uh the district
on um matters of education and safety of
uh their children
uh two is to um meet at least quarterly
with a District
administration uh to talk about um the
special needs uh program in the district
uh to look at development um evaluation
and planning for services uh to the
children in the district who have
disabilities uh providing input on
policies and practices and procedures in
the district
and really as a a means of more
communication between parents with
children with disabilities and uh the
school administration we've had I I
can't hesit I can't count the number of
pieces of legislation we've had about
special needs um since I've been here um
and some of the
testimony um has been uh
heart-wrenching um to listen to parents
and I think that we can improve things
by making sure the lines of
communication are open between the
parents and the school administration so
that's really the um the intent of the
bill um and then on page two um I'd like
to see um a workshop U at least annually
um to uh to inform uh parents um and to
answer any questions they have about
services and the uh Council should uh
produce a report at the end of the year
that goes to the school board um you
know it's important to deal with the
administration but uh the school board
should know what's uh going on um as
well and um there was um established
uh by the US Department of Education uh
office of special education programs a a
guide uh to these types of um parent
advisory councils and they have an
action uh excuse me a website called
advocacy and action and just let me read
the opening statement from the director
if I
could uh at the core of the individuals
with disabilities Education Act
lawmakers and Advocates established a
team of approach in which parents
Educators working together review
challenges explore options and make
decisions in the best interest of each
child the very teamwork and
collaboration are that are the core of
idea are also at the core of best
practice in special education these
local advisory councils an effective
local advisory Council takes the
teamwork of the IEP process one step
further putting parents in the role of
advisers who use their family
experiences unique perspectives and
expertise to influence the decisions and
help shape programs and policies at the
local level an effective local advisory
council is more than a meeting it is an
approach and a mindset that truly values
the advice of parents when parent
advisers are valued and engaged through
these local advisory councils they can
work together with School District staff
and community leaders to improve
education not only for those with
disabilities but for all
children um and I I think that's uh a
great goal and really why I'd like to
see these advisory councils um each
School District um and uh the advocacy
and action has many tools available for
um the local advisory councils to get
started with including um sample mission
statements um and um even um startup
checklists and um Flyers uh to uh invite
uh parents to
participate so
uh I I think that this
is important
legislation um when it comes to special
education and maybe is a step um in a
different direction than some of the
other legislation that we've had in the
past and uh I ask your support thank you
very
much sorry yes thank you madam chair uh
thank you for uh coming here and uh
testifying well me testifying but uh but
question on a clarification on it line
four uh the word shall what do
particularly put sh instead of
me
um basically sha makes it a requirement
for the school districts to form such a
council um I believe there are some
councils in place in some districts uh
but I want to make sure that they are
parent driven and not um Administration
Le
councils thank you um representative
Murray thank you madam chair um thank
you for taking me a question um in the
event that there is a district without a
local parent teacher organization how do
we it is enumerated I think there on
lines nine and 10 how how would you
suggest that folks would navigate that
um I I think uh an
organic uh establishment of a council um
uh I I see as as an option um if there
PTA uh representative Terry yes uh thank
you representative uh cordelli for your
um very uh cachent and helpful uh
presentation um with respect to the
introduction of this bill wondering if
you could tell us all um were there
other individuals or or groups that
contributed to your uh decision to bring
this bill forward could you characterize
for us um the the the ground swell if
there is any or any interest outside of
of this body right U it was just working
with um a number of uh special education
parents and Advocates that um I know
from um their uh frequent testimony um
before uh this and the previous
committee um so it was really
um parent
driven representative celik thank you
madam I have two separate questions if I
may um but I will ask for a followup
it's appropriate um the the first one
goes back to the comment about sh which
I appreciate the intent of sha I think
of school districts like the one in um
um Newington for example where they have
one Elementary School in the district
and that's it so would you be you know
this is up to 11 members I'm trying to
understand you know where they would
already potentially the you know the
parents of the school district's made up
of one principal they don't have a large
SAU or anything like that because it's
literally one k to five school um how
this would relate to those teeny tiny
districts without placing an undue
burden um since this is really an
organization of parents I I don't see
that it would be an uh a burden on the
uh School administration or the school
district itself um and um I that's why I
did not set uh a number of uh members of
the council because um of small uh
schools and uh districts that have just
um uh certain grade levels um such as
Newton or Quon and others may follow up
go ahead follow so again thinking of of
the um Newington School District you
know where there's 40 I think 47
children in the school so would you
think that having one parent would be a
sufficient number for a parent Council I
mean like I'm trying to think
proportionate Ely to my district which
has 2,000 students to create a
multi-member parent group works but
where there's only 44 kids or 40s
something and some of them are sibling
groups how you're going to find parents
who have the sufficient time and
capacity to do this
um I think that that would be a local um
a local issue but um I think that if
there are um parents um with uh children
for Disabilities um they would want to
um uh take part in this I I don't think
that um uh there will be a problem um in
finding parents to participate and it
could be you know two or three
parents you representative Murray thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question um with regard to um the
requirement that a district provide
adequate B resources available um uh one
of the things that you have enumerated I
I would assume falls under this line but
it is in SE section um six on page two
line three and four um it talks about
answering questions with the regard to
the rights of parents so my question to
you would be uh in this in in what is
considered adequate resources would this
be also potentially legal council or
some other entity advising parents of
what legal rights there are under idea
um
not necessarily if there is a workshop
is outlined you know that could be um
you know those types of questions could
be answered at an annual Workshop um but
the uh ongoing resources are more in the
line of of space um and if uh if they
wanted to um uh live stream a meeting or
something uh something along those lines
uh issues that I put that in because of
issues that had come up with the state
um advisory Council and um issues um in
having resources at the uh Department of
Education uh
facility yes phip thank you madam chair
um and so and the other question I did
have with with regard to the 11 or so
members as determined locally um how do
you determine how or how do you ensure
that a broad swath of um special
education needs are being represented
within this uh group of parent Advocates
there are a myriad of issues that um
parents deal with with children with
special ed needs so I you
know yeah I I didn't want to get into um
you know a number of parents with um
this category of disability child or
that I I would leave that up to uh local
decision-making but but hopefully they
would um Encompass um various um needs
children so I I I guess my curiosity is
then um are you asking parents to
self-disclose a a child's disability in
the application form or I I'm just
trying to make sure that there is when
we're talking about making sure that all
children are heard in a way that um
there there are so many different needs
with children idea sure um yes um um
that's why I uh um said that the meeting
should be open to all parents of
students with disabilities also so if um
there is uh someone with a particular um
child with unique situation um you know
they would be welcome um I I know I have
a daughter who's a special ed teacher
and for many years did life skills um
classes so that's definitely um a unique
uh set of students and uh um if there is
such a class I would hope a parent with
one of those childrens um would be uh
involved in the council as
well I'm gonna ask a question too do you
see any um connection at all between the
state advisory Council and any of these
councils um no
Direct a tie um you know perhaps the
local districts um could um provide
feedback to the state advisory Council
and you know maybe a good practice would
be for them uh someone from the local
Council to periodically uh be in contact
with the state Council or even appear at
their meetings and uh you know possibly
have the annual report uh sent to the
state advisory Council as well thank you
representative cel then thank you again
thinking about the makeup of parents as
those representing children who are have
varying types of learning disabilities
and other
disabilities I I'm trying to understand
how we're not violating the privacy of
the student through this because you
know um teachers aren't allowed to
disclose who in a classroom has an IEP
or 504 students who are receiving
special education services in settings
outside of the regular classroom
obviously you're identifi ifed as going
to that room but I'm just concerned that
this for students um who may already be
struggling with the stigma around having
an IEP or a learning disability um and I
speak from a place of experience around
this um that that having other parents
CE oh so you're one of those parents and
so I just wonder how this avoids that
potential um yeah I I don't know how
specific um the organization has to be
in terms of um saying we want you know a
parent um you know with a child with you
know ex disability or ex uh um learning
impairment um and I don't know that at
the council meetings um you parents are
free to disclose what they want to
disclose I don't think think it's a
requirement um in any way that um their
child's situation need to be
disclosed um you so I I I'm sorry I
don't see it as a a problem really um
representative Woodcock and then thank
you chairman good morning representative
qu again earlier morning CL I a couple
simple questions I'm assuming the
nitty-gritty of the parent organizations
and the selection and the applic process
it really doesn't say doesn't say here
who facilitates that of organizing that
and and I I know now that some local
organiz schools already have that I'm
not sure why we even need this but I
understand that but the part that I'm
assuming that's your intent that that
they'll sort of help up step up and help
out the part that concerned the cand is
is line 22 and
23 um on the uh draft of this bill and
it talks specifically about this
organization being part of the
evaluation of District special education
programs and I'm not sure what that
means I'm not sure how a parent advis
committee should be in the official role
of evaluating School District programs
uh this program or any other particular
program and I don't know how it's going
to play out I think I just see that as a
conflict um between being advisory to
the board to the administration and they
say we're going to be the ones that are
going to help evaluate this that really
concerns me right um I view
evaluation um more in uh looking and uh
experience um with um the programs at
the school and the parents um advising
um based on their
experience um I I view that as the
meaning of evaluation their experience
and observations um of uh various uh
programs and services um you know if
there are um issues with uh um
you I certain uh certain meetings IEP
meetings um I would think that they
would want to make the district would
want to know parents opinions on um what
is taking place and uh ways that uh uh
things could be improved uh for uh the
parents as well and the children
thank you m thank you representative
litfield thank you for taking the
question are you simply looking to give
these parents of children with special
needs of voice and would the 11 members
be completely
voluntary uh right participation is
voluntary yes and that's why I uh
started out by saying This was
parent-driven um you know I want parents
to have a um a voice um and uh provide
feedback um as um was outlined um by the
director of U advocacy and act action um
you know it should be um a teamwork
effort between parents and School
administration uh to make sure that uh
adequate uh services to those childrens
are are being
provided
followup again just confirming under the
Privacy issue since they are the parents
and it's volunteer it would be up to
them whether or not they share any of
what is going on within their child's
life that is correct thank you in my
opinion thank you representative Terry
yes thank you uh just returning for a
moment to lines 22 and 23 could you
confirm
or disagree with my reading that the
role of the parents with respect to
these uh meetings and participation in
the Planning Development evaluation of
the District special education programs
that they would be the role of the
parents would be contributory and not
determinative because they don't have a
vote and and they they're not charged
with making the decisions so we're
casting a wide net bringing in and I
hate to over use of the term
stakeholders but they're important
people and should be heard would you
agree with that yes um yeah I am I
reading that correctly yeah I I don't uh
uh anticipate or see that a value a
would um mean any kind of scorecard and
Grading of programs um anything like
that it's right based on experience
thanks representative Murray and then
Bon thank you madam chair um thank you
for taking my question with regard to
line 28 on page one um the way I'm
reading this and correct me if I'm wrong
this is a council responsibility of this
11 person uh Council to serve as a
resource for parents is including
providing information on state and
federal rights to students is that what
you meant that the that that the body
itself provides its own information on
States and federal rights I I would
think that they would be uh they would
have um information available for
instance on um uh the parent information
center that they could provide um to uh
you know um you know websites phone
numbers those types of resources for
further information for parents uh
disability rights Center parent
information center those
organizations representative
Bon thank you madam chair and thank you
for uh taking my question um as you know
um the state advisory committee is now
bit disbanded because of uh difficulty
in getting membership so starting again
at the beginning so uh part of my
concern is getting enough interested
parents to do this as a um and to just
go on them and also with the composition
of the committee itself um it in
advisory capacity um you have parents
who have a lot of individual experiences
and know a lot about the law and I
applaud the abil the the concept is
great I think that parents should be
involved um and the workshop is an
excellent idea to man mandate an
excellent Workshop giving them all that
information um but if it is an advisory
committee and you only have parents on
the committee with their knowledge um
there's no um people on that committee
that do have institutional knowledge on
it would it behoove the committee uh to
um put like one educational professional
on it as well thank you um I I would
certainly um see them inviting in um uh
professional people maybe uh maybe
someone from the disability rights
Center or
um uh even uh the special education
Advocate to come in and talk uh to the
parents and maybe answer questions that
they have um provide them some guidance
um so I you know I I don't see it as a
closed meeting between the parents um
but certainly being able to um invite
someone in um you know much like we do
with study
committees followup please followup
um in addition to that I was just
wondering since it is phrase as an
advisory Council being on a school board
myself anytime we have any kind of
advisory committees to the school board
uh the school board is involved in the
selection of those members on the parent
uh teachers associations or that they
they serve a different Mission this is a
very specific Mission and um I would
think that you would want Schoolboard
members involved in uh deciding who
you were you looking for an for an
answer I I I took a different direction
in terms of the uh initial
organization representative Murray then
representative Paul thank you uh Madam
chair um with respect to the fiscal
analysis or the methodology it does seem
to indicate that there might be some
cost to the local um community and local
expenditure
um so I was curious um because you are
requiring certain
um things to be provided by the district
I I wonder where we are at in
understanding the scope of what the cost
potentially could
be I I don't Envision um a large cost at
all um you know maybe at some point
there there might be some uh
copying um
uh I I I I don't see a large cost Factor
at all
here representative
Hall thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I just want to make
sure that I'm I'm right so the power of
this committee is really through the
parent teacher organization cor right in
terms of the makeup of the committee
they make the decisions on who serves it
on
it I I think that there is a a section
in terms of
um um
I think there was something in here
about
vacancies but it
uh the initial setup should should be um
Again by by parents I think um and the
membership should be parents I I
definitely want this um to be uh a
parent organization rather than a uh
District ad
uh District
organization followup
followup um so and thank you for taking
my question again so they're making it
up so this the PTO is choosing the
people on this Council those PTO members
may not be special needs parents at all
and probably not and they are the ones
that are going to choose these folks
from from the um from the parents who
indicate interest in being on the
council yes so but but all of it the
makeup of the committee lies with the
parent teacher organization if you don't
have a parent teacher organization as
what mentioned earlier then that could
be problematic but okay thank you
representative Lichfield no okay
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair my other question is with regard
to like the PTO PTA status I mean as far
as how they operate generally is a like
a fundraising organization arm of school
does this potentially put any of those
efforts at risk because we're
co-mingling efforts between District
initiatives and yeah I I don't see that
they're just involved in um uh selecting
um parents who want to be on the council
um they're not going to be council
members um unless they have a child with
a
disability all
right represent s um would you amend
this to to allow guardianship as well as
parents or does it have to be this
specifies parents and not Guardians yeah
it probably should include parents or
Guardians yes okay any other
questions thank you oh representative
Richfield thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question would
you be open to any other organizations
other than the
PTO uh being the on to to decide this
um it's uh it's the committee Bill and
um I I think that uh if you have other
thoughts um you can uh draft an
amendment and um you know I'm I'm not uh
um going to I don't have veto power or
anything so uh you know yeah sure thank
you all right thank you representative
oh okay and you're ni Nicole we'll
switch that around and
up thank you U Mr chairman and the
committee and Madam chairman um my name
is Nicole sheath I'm a resident of
exitor New Hampshire and I'm uh
pediatric occupational therapist I've
been that for 20 years and I'm also a
mother and advocate of four children um
ages 11 16 20 and 24 that all have
disabilities all my children have had
individual education plans during their
school careers they've all received par
professional support two of my children
have been placed out of district and one
of my children have had several years in
residential
placement I being an occupational
therapist sit on both sides the table
and special ed I'm responsible for
writing IEPs and goals and services for
other people's children and also sitting
and working with my school team
on advocating for my children's goals
services and educating them
on my knowledge as a parent of who my
children are and what works best for
them I have provided a lot of Education
materials for my team over the years um
so they can decipher when my daughter
puts herself into a display case because
she's
overstimulated whether or not that's
related to sensory processing if it's
truly Behavior or if she's presenting
with some post-traumatic stress which
she does have so really helping the team
identify what it is and how best to work
with
her five years ago I made the decision
to quit my job as an occupational
therapist I
was working two full-time jobs
managing my work and also managing my
kids schools therapies medical
appointments it was basically working to
full job time jobs and the burnout
was it was UN unreal I was not
myself I've been working with school
districts for my children for 21 years
as soon as my son turned three My First
three I have never had time over my 21
meeting my time and my priority are
given to my kids their therapies their
medical
appointments outlying an IEP writing
calls my children have experienced
isolation and exclusion by their peers
and sometimes staff and many times
they're unable to participate in a
schoolwide
event my days typically are and were
working 8 hour days as an O te driving
home making dinner going to various
appointments Fielding crisis College
from the school driving to 45 minutes to
an hour to pick up my children attending
progress meetings and IEP meetings and
still trying to develop peer connections
for my children who have no
friends I have no time to make food for
the staff luncheon that was organized by
the
PTO I have no time to organize a
fundraiser for the school with
PTO anytime I had to
dedicate time was helping my children
with
self-care accessing their Community
working and
sleeping I've come before this committee
to ask that you do approve hb21 with
amendments I also ask that you review
some attached material that I will out
at the end which includes legislation
from established um CPAC which is a
special education parent advisory
Council from Colorado Virginia Michigan
and
Missouri a school district special
education parent advisory council is one
way I could work to advocate for my
children's needs while also connecting
with my community this community would
allow parents of children with
disabilities and self- Advocates to have
a seat at the table a and be
heard my family's normal is not normal
for most people so why would I expect
those who do not live my life to know
what is best for my children's
education I'm very thankful for chairman
cordelli for um commenting on the
advocacy and action guide that was um
produced under the US Department of
Education Office of special ed um in
2018 in my um testimony I've referenced
a lot from
that um guide
book it states that a CPAC can increase
the pro proactive productive involvement
of families by inviting their input in
ways that can be used to shape local
special education policy families can
provide direct input to school district
leaders about policies programs
practices and services that have an
impact on students with
disabilities by using parent input a
CPAC can help improve educational
outcomes and well-being for all students
including those with disabilities help
identify unmet needs and help shape the
development of programs services and
policies as well as improve District
culture its purpose to advise Advocate
and offer guidance and not to decide
policy and that is right from the guide
book The advocacy and action um guide
book that
chair um Celli mentioned um utilized
information
from 400 parent Center
leaders um to learn more about interests
and priorities for this guide they
completed interviews detailed interviews
with parent centers and they used
research from state level
leaders this information was
collaborated from states of California
Connecticut Iowa Indiana Kansas
Louisiana Maine Massachusetts Michigan
New Jersey New York Ohio Pennsylvania
Washington the Amendments that I would
request are linked to line 9 through 10
which states states the initial council
is selected by representatives from
local parent teacher
organizations line 11 through 12 says
subsequent council members include
including any vacancies shall be
reviewed and voted by a selection
committee composed of current council
members and representatives from local
parent and teacher
organizations in my lived experience
there is no guarantee that members of
the PTO know the benefits barriers
limitations of the special district
special ed process I request the council
amend
by appointing a local school
board
um
where parents and caregivers would apply
through open application process through
the local school board I also request
that at least half of the committee be
parents of children with disabilities or
individuals with
disabilities lived experience is
necessary to provide input on policies
program practices and services that have
an impact on students with disabilities
and their
families going back to the guide book it
states that me from other from
information gathered from other states
that membership of a CPAC may include
parents of children with disabilities
who may have an ie School leaders
including District or County Supervisors
of special ed services or members of the
board of
education teachers child study team
members related service professionals
School staff students and former
students adults with disabilities School
staff with disabilities representatives
from charter schools
from homeschools advocates for children
who are homeless or in Foster Care
Advocates for children who are in
Correctional fil facilities nursing
homes or hospitals and any parent or
Community member committed to improving
district uh CPAC should be inclusive as
possible if you look at like disability
is diversity and if you look at a Field
of Flowers every single flower is
different but it still makes that
field so getting back to um the concern
of child privacy that was brought up by
representative Murray um and also
s my story when I tell my story it takes
back the power for my children and my
family Disability should not be shamed
it should be celebrated and if we use
Universal Divine then we can help
everybody benefits of a a CPAC help
include Outreach positive relationships
collaborative problem solving system
teams based on input trusted source of
information information sharing improve
improved service in programs and deepen
trust with school leaders and
families some of the research that I I
found is that um for funding and
resources for these districts
programs the doe offers some form of
information guidance and technical
assistance and offer partnering with pi
um and can help distribute federal funds
to support projects to build sustain and
improve these parent advocacy
programs State councils on developmental
disability are federal
funded and these
organizations can help families like
mine
obtain grants and um Monies to help with
child
care how are how are some of my kids how
are some families supposed to attend
these meetings if they don't have child
care mileage making sure that that
barrier is off the table to be able to
get to these meetings but looking at the
disability um the DD Council for looking
at some grant
funding also using resarch es from the
University centers of excellence unh's
Institute of disability being able to
have the workshops that you mentioned
chair um for these committees using what
we have we have great resources in the
state so I thank you chairing the
committee for listening to my
testimony and reviewing the references
that I provide and again I ask that you
pass hb21 with amendments for the
appointment of council members by
District School Board and sure half of
each local committee is represented by
families of people with disabilities
thank you are there any questions thank
you um any questions
for representative Cel and then
represent thank you so much and thank
you for taking my question and for your
very impressive testimony um would would
you also encourage um if it's a school
district that has more than one grade uh
like like an elementary school but a
district that is multi- levels that this
say that should it be appropriate it uh
reflect a variety of age levels well and
I think that's how I read the bill was
that it was District by District so to
me being an exitor I'm siu6 and we have
five schools six schools in siu6 so to
me there would be representation from
all towns and schools on this parent
advisory committee representative
litfield thank you madam chair thank you
so much for sharing your story and for
your testimony
my initial question which I think you
might have already covered um but
initially when I looked at this and I
was seeing PTO I was kind of going down
the Avenue of should we actually have
maybe the school nurse be involved or a
guidance counselor because they know the
children's specific history versus
having it out there with the PTO
although I feel guilty saying that
because there is no shame in it and you
made a great point right um I'm just
wondering if I could ask you as a parent
and as someone in the field how do you
feel about that do you do you feel PTO
or do you think maybe nurse guidance
counselor or I don't think the PTO has
um is at least in my lived
experience the experience I mean there
are members of my PTO that do have
children with disabilities and do have
IEPs I'm not saying that but I cannot
say that a PTO is the expert on choosing
members for a special ed committee
to me it's by open
application and if we're building
involvement with
parents and teachers and special
Educators and the people who are making
the policy then the parents do want a
voice in that so to me this this um CPAC
is building a bridge between the people
who are making the policies and the
people who live the
policies and having that com
conversation and having people with
disabilities and parents and families
and Guardians who have children with
disabilities express some of those
things that sound like a good idea but
really when you implement it it
backfires so really opening that
conversation and that's where I really
see this committee thriving is that it
gives way that as parent I'm not sitting
at a table with all these
professionals and I'm the expert of my
children right I'm also an occupational
therapist so I do demand my goals are
measurable and I I highlight so I have a
different Viewpoint um and I have more I
think validity because I'm a
professional where I think a lot of my
friends that are just parents feel like
oh I'm just the parent so I think a a
committee like this really puts
everybody at an even place
we're not making policy but we're
discussing policy we're getting
education we're we're bringing in pick
we're bringing in DD councel we're
bringing in information from um UNH
Institute of disability we're educating
this the staff we're educating the
parents and we're helping to just work
together and I think that is how I took
the point of this spill and I may be
incorrect but I have testified and and
if you'd like to know I'm not going to
tell horror
stories that you had mentioned but when
I tell my story people are like how are
you even
alive and I'll tell you right
now there were days I didn't want to be
because it's really hard thank you
follow followup thank
you two parts if I may so I just want to
confirm I heard you that you said open
application yep not through the PTO no
through the school board through the
school board okay thank you and then um
I had just assumed the 11 parents would
be parents all parents of children with
special needs that's not how I read that
okay I read 11 parents and um to me uh
my perception would be I would I do want
I think because we're talking about
students in general disabilities and not
disabilities I think it's really
important that you have a myriad of
everybody with
expertise because ultimately we want
inclusion I don't want my my son or
daughter put in a
room with a teacher where they have no
social interaction except for at lunch
my kids haven't had friends since second
grade like peers feared my
children so to me if their needs were
met and their classrooms were set up in
a way that benefited everybody
and you had you would actually be
creating opportunities for Te for
students to become and want to be OTS
pts speech and language Pathologists
teachers principles because they are
then the peer teachers of children with
disabilities and then the benefits of my
children have friends and peers and
models so I think you know I wouldn't
say it has to be all parents with just
uh andard audience with disabilities I
think it I would request that half have
our families and or self- Advocates or
staff with disabilities because they
have the LED experience they know what's
wored what they've been through what
doesn't and to your point um and I
cannot remember who had said it but that
every every parent and every child with
experiences and we work the best when
we're collaborating and we're
brainstorming as a team I don't want to
interrupt but could you shut the doors
there please sure thank you any other
questions thank you very much thank you
I do have
pass
myself just pass just put him down there
we'll pass him around thank you all
four thank you I'd like to call Vanessa
Madam chair members of the committee
thank you very much for hearing me today
my name is Vanessa blae and I serve as
the Director of policy in planning at
the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities um and we
love it when parents come here and do
our job for us um we are here today
because we want to Second um our
concerns about the stipulations in this
policy um it's on its face it's a great
idea we want parents um with students in
supportive education to have their
voices heard um we believe that it's
very important in the advancements of
inclusion and integration in the
education system um we have concerns
about the membership stipulations or
what we think our lack of um I'll try to
be as brief as possible I members of our
staff and members of our Council sit on
many advisory committees um some of them
are successful and some of them are not
and a lot of times it really comes down
to how well the policy that formulated
that advisory committee is written um a
lot of times we go back to our statute
and we look and see what who what is our
committee supposed to be made up of um
what are are their goals what are their
responsibilities um so we really believe
that this um bill could use a little bit
more work in order to give the voices
that we want to be heard a chance to be
heard um and we also want to keep in
mind that unfortunately there's a lot of
divisiveness in communities around
supportive education because a lot of
people think it's expensive um so we
want to make sure that when we're
creating an advisory committee that is
created in a way that demands respect
from the people who are involved um and
not something that is going to become
ineffective because of voices that are
drowning out um the other voices that
that should be heard because when we
improve supportive education we improve
education for all of our students and we
have to keep that in mind this is this
is the aim for all of us we all want our
children to have the best education that
they possibly can have have um our
membership is made up of 60% of people
with the lived experience of disability
and or their parents or Guardians and
they are very happy to have the
opportunity to work um with legislators
on giving their input on what they feel
would be impactful legislation so please
feel free to reach out to our Council
anytime um and we are very happy to talk
with you
questions uh thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question so um
clearly you you think the concept is
good but you're recommending some
changes other uh you just mentioned
really one specific one in terms of me
uh membership are there other um
suggestions you would make to make our
statute better um typically the council
doesn't directly make suggestions about
Amendment changes I can I can say that
we believe that um the application
process and the the theory of having
pto's um formulate the Committees um
would not give leverage necessarily in
certain districts to the voices of
people who should be heard in
formulating the committee um we're also
concerned about the smaller districts
because you know New Hampshire is we're
a weird State we have big districts and
we have tiny districts and we want to
make sure that um if we're going to task
districts to um have this kind of
advisory committee and and respect this
advisory committee um that we have to
consider all of the different makeups of
the districts when we're when we're
creating this type of legislation I hope
that answers your
question it does thank you
any other
questions representative litfield thank
you and thank you for taking my question
so I understand what you're saying about
smaller districts there are being issues
my question to you
is right now you're correct maybe in
certain districts there are certain
people that maybe they feel resentful
toward that special education budget and
maybe they need more education on that
wouldn't this be a great way to kind of
bring light to that and to bring the
groups together do you know what I'm
saying like in other words humanize the
situation where if you have let's say
six parents of children with special
needs and then six parents not or
something on this committee but you're
bringing them together where you may
Forge bonds or friendships or see things
in a different light that you may not
have before and it may even lead to
inclusiveness to something as simple as
a birthday party which which is not so
simple when you're in second grade
because it's all relative what is your I
just feel as though this bill might be a
great first step to breaking the ice and
I'm confused about the hesitation so I'd
love to hear your feedback on that the
the hesitation isn't necessarily about
forming the advisory councils it's it's
just cautioning that when we are
developing this type of legislation that
we want to take those things into
consideration of course we want all
parents to understand the benefits of
providing equal education for all of our
students um the smaller
districts it's it it can be difficult
for parents because they are a target of
harassment um in certain places because
of the cost of of special education
that's it's something that happens it's
unfortunate um we're not we don't
believe it should stop this type of um
opportunity for parents to be heard we
want to make sure that we are not
creating an environment that would
harassment any other questions thank you
very much appreciate thank you and I'd
hi thank you for having me um you sit
real close to the mic sit real close
okay sorry um thank you very much for
inviting me up here
um I am 100% for this bill I have a
almost 9-year-old son um and hearing you
speak of your family um I know that
someone had mentioned about maybe having
a
nurse I think it was you know choose I
come from a district that has um Four
elementary schools and it's all
considered one District there's not
different Wars in it um and I don't
think I I know you had also mentioned
where the school board um maybe could
help in choosing the parents for the
committee um I don't think all school
school boards are aware of what we're
being put through as
parents um I don't think I think it gets
to a point where and and with
confidentiality too when we're brought
in for an IEP meeting we have to meet
down in the lobby and then you get
walked up to the same room so everyone
knows why you're going to that room
because there is you've got the entire
IEP team in that room the door is closed
so they know you have someone with who
has an IEP or vial 4 so there's no way
of keeping that as I mean when you walk
through the school and you're brought up
to that room everybody
knows she's here because her son has
something my son has s
disabilities I've been fighting his IEP
since October of 23 we have not come to
an
agreement
and I had to learn all this on my own
and then I did end up getting an
advocate from conquer um immediately
when the doctors had started noticing it
I went and took every book out on
IEPs and 504s from the local library and
read every single one of them I've had a
neuros pych done on my
son this school district will not agree
to it 38 Pages he has 11 eye diagnosises
as well as six other diagnosises he's on
the
Spectrum
and when you try to he is he has the
bigest heart he's not a behavioral he's
an introvert so he can't Express that at
school without being scared inside those
walls so and I know each parent has a
different I volunteered at his school in
the office and I know each parent has
different they they see different
things do I think having someone from
the IEP team so to speak choose um which
parents no because they ultimately have
the final say you don't you can say what
you how you feel but ultimately they're
the ones who make up that IEP they're
the ones who say yes or no so I don't
think that they should be able to yes
they may know some of the things maybe a
special ed
teacher can join in on that I don't
think the nurse knows fully to what
extent they may know some of the medical
conditions But ultimately when it comes
down to it it's us parents who know what
we go through I
know and I'll give an example I I get
criticized because I don't ask my son
the minute he walks through the door how
was your day at
school I can't because that triggers him
and he's in his safe
place so with this being said I I just
can't I think it would be great for
other for committee to be able to
discuss these things and have them maybe
meet up so I know with board meetings
there's the non-public board meeting
prior to maybe once a month have the
advisory committee that of the parents
meet up or have one's for the the
chairperson of that committee go in and
speak and speak the concerns because
right now you can't get into a non
board public meeting without going
through a very long process to get there
and you could be denied when asking that
so in that aspect I
think I like the fact of having some
parents that don't under don't have a
child with disabilities but they don't
all understand they could sit there and
look at you like why is he having a
meltdown all he did was trip
but you as a parent know why he is
having a
meltdown I know if my son comes home and
he has a
meltdown something happened at school
but I have to let him tell me I can't
pull it out of him so in that case I
guess with the the the Privacy there's
no privacy in our district because you
walk in like I said you walk into a room
and I am I am I embarrassed of myself
son absolutely not because I chose at 40
to have this child that was a miracle I
myself have health
issues um but it is literally a
full-time job to advocate for
them and I think that had I not gone and
learned what I did or read the laws in
the library I don't and I don't think
some parents have time to do that I only
because I am disabled
I had time to go and do
it so in that case I 100% think it would
be amazing to have this type of
committee to be able to have them voice
concerns that we're having I've been
going to the budget meetings and the
school board meetings just to learn so I
could see what the schools are going
through maybe there's something I can do
to
help um so so in that case I I 100% for
this but as to who would choose
it I I don't know if I could go with
anyone from the I AP team let's see if
people have questions okay thank you
anybody have any questions for
representative
litfield thank you thank you and thank
you for sharing and I do want to say
that your son is a miracle and he's very
blessed to have you thank you thank you
for being here today
so my question to you is and I I heard
you say you don't really know who should
be the one to pick yeah I don't know
either I don't know if the rest of the
committee does my my gut feeling is not
PTO or PTA um I don't know if School
Board is best I had brought up nurse
only because of the confidentiality
Factor although you're right there
probably is no confidentiality would you
be comfortable with it being the school
board if the school board was well aware
of what issues going on with special
education in within their
District I then I would feel comfortable
um with that I I I think there in that
case um there are a couple on our school
board that would be wonderful to choose
from them because they do
um they do see that uh
they they're for the kids and it's not
money thank you any other questions
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman good morning thank you for
coming in it's always difficult to
testify something so personal we
appreciate your input early on in your
conversation you indicated that I think
if I heard you rightly correctly um that
she'd go on to uh the the uh advocacy to
get an advocate in conget and my
question is did that work for you we are
still working he is amazing
The Advocate that I got so the
the man yes thank you so the process of
having a a Advocate that's already
provided that already knows the laws and
all things seems to be working Su
success successfully in terms of more
particular perhaps better than a a local
organization of PTA
people um yes I'm also on the PTA for
our district so um I do a lot of
volunteering with that
um but with the advocate I know that
there is only a certain amount that
conquer has for the entire State okay so
it makes it difficult I mean he he
guides on Timothy's behalf but what we
want to say and I sorry I didn't mean to
mention my son's name but on my son's
behalf he does advise on that but in the
beginning I didn't have an advocate I
had to wait several months do yeah
different is okay thank you so much for
your testimony thank you Mr any other
questions seeing that thank you very
much thank you very much like to call
Heather
Barker good morning thank you for
letting me speak I am the student
service director for nhsaa here in
conquer previously I was a director of
student services in a school district
and before that I worked for many years
as an administrator and educator in a
large Middle School here in New
Hampshire as both a general Ed and
administrator I actually love the idea
of um a parent advisory Council in fact
as a
director I had one in the school
district that I worked in I would love
to say I would fully support this bill
however I think it does need some
reworking I think it's invaluable to
have parent voice in an advising way uh
I do think there is a separation between
advocacy when a parent needs an advocate
and that that Avenue in special
education and procedural safeguards and
rights however I think as a director uh
when I came into my position there was
already an established Council they met
with the director and the superintendent
monthly uh it could be virtual as we
moved into that virtual place it would
be in person it was usually a
combination cuz some parents could not
leave they had things going on with
their children so it was flexible in
that manner we established they the
parents established sort of the uh
operations of it we didn't have a formal
secretary and all those pieces although
we kept notes and we shared those we
partnered it with a I ran a weekly
parent conversation which was a zoom
call for any parent to come into a live
zoom and talk about what was going on in
our district and things they wanted help
with so really creating voice for all
parents but this advisory Council was
really crucial and if you look down at
uh 2021 22 23 24 25 and 26 27 and
28 okay they did a phenomenal job
advising me as to what was going on at
the different levels so we had a
representative for preschool we had a
representative for each of the levels in
our district there were three lower
elementaries an upper elementary a
middle and a high school and I also
included an at a District Parent because
I felt it was very important to hear
what their lived experiences were and to
find opportunities for those children
and youth to connect somehow in their
communities since this is where they
lived so in terms of membership and all
those pieces it was homegrown so I'm not
suggesting you want to leave it up to
Homegrown but I do think having if you
go up in that uh the paragraph two as
other members uh other folks have said
here today I love the idea of an
application process however it is very
hard to get people to join things so
some people these were all volunteers or
we sought them out and I actually did
not seek out parents who were having a
wonderful experience with special
education in the district I was really
interested in hearing from parents who
were not having that experience I also
felt it was terribly important um to
understand as we were making policy or
uh transition between Grade
spans uh special education process
procedure forms as as simplest forms I
did not know that all the different
buildings had their own forms as a
parent moving through that it changed
every time you went to a new place so
without having had that advisory Council
I wouldn't have known that when we did
things like um at the high school when
kids would go home for testing midterms
and finals all of our students who are
in very specialized programs who were
not participating that also went home I
didn't know about that till parents told
me that and we made the change so those
students and their program people
because all that staff was there we kept
them at school so there were wonderful
things that came out of having that
parent voice and that
participation with the student service
director and the superintendent I
brought I had a weekly um administrative
counsil of our entire District all the
ad administrators we I had a standing
conversation there was a time every
single month when I talked about what
parents talked about what were some of
their concerns and issues and we
addressed those so I came into that
culture and I kept it going but I found
it invaluable so for me if we looked at
um having the PTA I know just from my
own experience and working with in
schools and also in the communities
where I have lived there's they're
having trouble getting people even
attending PTA or PTO meetings so I'm not
sure that's the right Avenue um maybe it
is a school board member and the
director I think not having the director
or someone like that participating to
understand and hear what the concerns
are even if you make them a listening
member I'm not sure um I think you're
going to miss out on that piece uh
because that's how that can be brought
to the district and actually have action
take place so this is an informing group
an advising group but if we actually
want to affect positive change for all
students and our most vulnerable
Learners we really need to have people
at that table who can actually bring
that forward to other places I also love
having the uh the reporting out to the
community having that quarterly meeting
with folks with the parents and
attendance we did not do that that's a
great idea so I think this is a
wonderful idea and with either
amendments or some reworking some of the
language I would fully support this
Bill thank you any other questions uh
representative B Bon uh thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um could you just uh I I'm
didn't quite get it at the beginning uh
what was your role in two things what
was your role and what was the size of
the district that you were working with
sure so um my role in The District was
the student director of student services
so central office
administrator responsible for overseeing
all of the the special education in the
school
district and the size of the district
was 3600
students you representative Murray um
yes thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my question so if I heard you
correctly you said you would be in
support of stratifying perhaps the mix
of cohort of of participants to be
preschool elementary middle and high
school age Learners to make sure that
you're getting a broad section of a
lived experience for those Learners in
those age groups yeah let me respond to
that so we our group was actually it was
six members they were all parents who
had children with disabilities I do love
the idea of including a couple I don't
know how many I see when you start to
get too big it's a challenge right but
having uh parents who do not have
children with disabilities is also
helpful having an educator there if you
could do that that would be great um or
other members we had people Flex in and
out of that group we invited people to
come in fact we partnered with P the
parent information center we offered
parent evenings and did trainings based
on surveys that that group working with
me sent out to parents what do you want
more information about a lot of parents
wanted to understand the specialed
process to be able to Advocate better
for their child and IEP team meetings
they wanted training so we partnered
with pck I encouraged and the parents uh
actually became went through the
advocacy training that we made a
brochure that group made a brochure that
that went to out it was available at
parent nights and at the beginning of
the year and it was
online okay they had a they had a
Facebook page they had a social media
presence and they had their own contact
information so parents knew at each
building they could contact that person
for help and I often got phone calls
from those folks saying that a parent
sometimes it was Anonymous sometimes the
parent they connected me to a parent who
was
experiencing difficulty around a
situation and I partnered with the
parent in the school right to wrap
around that situation so there are so
many things positive things that can
happen from this I think truthfully it
depends on the size of the
district that's where I think there has
to be some leeway in the language of How
It's configured because that's going to
be important so again you can't say
there's got to be a rep of all those
places but in my district given its size
to me it was terribly important to have
all of those pieces so that you really
understood that one of the other values
was many of the parents who were in the
upper elementary middle and high school
had experienced preschool and the lower
elementary so there were some really
great
conversations about either things that
had remained challenges or barriers or
things that had improved or things we
hadn't thought about about so I think
when you start thinking about the that's
where I'm saying it might need a little
more
work represent s thank you thank you
very much and thank you for taking my
question sure um would would you be
comfortable if the makeup of the group
was made up of people who not only
volunteered to be on it but who had made
contact with whomever the special
services director was for that district
for the so that they would be able to
maintain whatever privacy they chose but
also in terms of you know abilities and
not or or challenges and then also um
ensuring that Brad her
overview so having listened to the
testimony that I heard I'm not sure all
parents would feel that the student
services director if there was a
conflict going on between the school and
the parent would feel that that's the
person so I'm not really sure for me it
was really very clear that I was very
open to having that parent voice and I'm
not s suggesting other directors are not
but I do think that that might create
hesitation how it initially worked was
um I sought
volunteers um they met with me very
briefly there was no interview nothing
like that I had other folks that were on
that advisory Council suggest parents um
parents came to my office and said I'd
like to be on this so
that was how it happened but again this
was a Grassroots thing it was a local
thing um I an invaluable thing so I
think finding a pathway to create this
opportunity for parents to have a voice
and to truly be our partners in special
education which will ultimately impact
right
inclusion general education education
for all children we are certainly better
together
so good follow so would you potentially
recommend an amendment that would say
that each district should determine the
best strategy for creating the group
based on the size and needs of their
district with the caveat that perhaps
you have if you have a robust PTA
there's some membership from there
helping with that so that bridges that
concern that some parents might have
that oh I wouldn't be included because
I've been in Conflict something like
that I think there has to be some Avenue
for all parents to be able if they want
to participate to actually be able to if
there's a possibility I I would be
thrilled if this was there were so many
parents that wanted to do this I you
know that they were all applying I'm not
sure that will be the case that would be
great any other
questions seeing none thank you very
Wilson good morning madam M chair
members of the committee thank you for
taking my testimony today uh for the
record Becky Wilson from the New
Hampshire school boards Association uh
we certainly share and support the
underlying premise of this bill to try
to ensure that there are Avenues and
good communication between school
districts School boards and parents with
disabilities um however to share some of
the concerns from previous speakers we'd
like to just offer uh we do have some
concerns about some of the language in
the bill and a few other points I just
would like to make um we'd like to just
REM as the previous speaker said many
districts do have um I won't call them
parent advisory councils but student
family Partnerships Family School
partnership groups focused on uh the
provision for students with disabilities
in their districts I've shared similar
experiences in the past as the previous
speaker where those groups were um from
the ground up that were born out of
wanting to try to increase positive
communication between families who have
students with disabilities and the
school district um multiple districts
those were chosen in very different ways
um all of the groups that I worked with
during my time as a special ed director
prior to my time at the school boards
Association also had an outside agency
or Association that facilitated those
groups so that there was some
equalizing um person either from the
parent Information Center New Hampshire
family voices does a wonderful job of
helping facilitate those groups um and
those the role of the person from those
agencies was really to help the group
understand and decide how they were
going to make decisions um how they were
going to incorporate new members make
sure there were some processes in place
to protect student privacy things like
that um those groups also the members of
those groups offer to become Vol uh
mentors to families who are new to the
district or new to the special education
process in the district so that those
people had additional roles the people
that served on those committees all did
that as a volunteer um they were thought
out in many different ways and the
makeup of those committees was very um
personalized depending on the district
in which those groups happened um so we
would suggest potentially the
consideration of having some other um
training aspect for the group if these
were to go forward which we feel is a
very positive um aspect of making sure
that the group is functioning I think
you've heard in other uh testimony on
bills not this particular Bill about
large groups of people trying to
facilitate some of these conversations
and some of the challenges that can come
along with that so uh we also would just
want to be mindful of the fact that
school boards by Design are limited as
to what they can and cannot know in
terms of students with disabilities in
the district that is very intentional
given the fact that the school board is
also the entity that is uh involved in
student discipline hearings manifest
education hardship perhaps some other
types of hearings or information down
the road in terms of students with
disabilities in their District um um
having
them uh choose members of this committee
and whatever information would be
provided to the school board as a result
of that application process could be of
concern I think when Schoolboard members
then perhaps down the line need to be
involved with these families in a
different manner um we would want to be
really cautious about uh the fact that
while we understand that these meetings
would be public um and open to the
public and that there are minutes uh
according to this bill that are being
taken that are also going to be made
public to ensure somehow that those
meetings are again um there's some
training and facilitation around what it
means to have a public meeting with
parents of PE people with disabil or
people with disabilities things that
could be potentially shared at those
meetings how that would be um you know
captured in a way that would make sure
that there's not even parents or
students who are not part of that
committee that those cases are not being
discussed at the public meeting or how
are those being recorded in the minutes
to just be really cautious about all of
that and make sure that there's some
ways to do that um we also just want to
remind the committee that there are a
number of school districts in the state
that do not operate a school at least 10
I think at this point um so I'm not sure
they would definitely not have a PTO I
don't believe nor would they have enough
parents to make this group up uh this
bill is very specific about the fact
that it's for every school district so I
think that would need to be addressed in
terms of districts that don't operate a
school um um or how you would protect
against student and family privacy in
those situations just be mindful but uh
we certainly want to be clear that um
increasing positive communication
between families of students with
disabilities and the school district is
something that we greatly support uh
this has been very successful in other
uh districts that have done this on
their own there are a number of them uh
I would ask the committee to sort of
reach out to your local school districts
and find out if you do have a family
school partnership team or some other uh
version of a special ed advisory
committee in your District because many
many districts do this already happy to
take any questions representative Murray
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um I do have two
small questions so I'll I'll I'll ask
them in uh the first question I think
you and the previous speaker had talked
about training in some mechanism would
this be an outside organization that
would offer this at new charge or would
this be a charge to the Local District
how do you envision that training or
where where would that come from thank
you for the question representative I
think uh it depends on the district um
and what the needs are of the district
so there's been many occasions where
there are broad trainings that would be
offered across the state and different
districts in regards to parental rights
and special education um the IEP process
the evaluation process things like that
that are really General trainings there
are districts who might um as a result
of having this kind of group Identify
some areas of need in their District
such as um you know uh how to have a
collaborative team meeting what to do if
you get stuck as a team uh what are some
other area agencies that are available
to support families in your area those
kinds of trainings are really um built
from that committee making a decision
about what are the needs of the district
and then there are times where maybe you
have a district expert so to speak who
could present that alongside a parent or
perhaps you're seeking out somebody to
come in and do that training um New
Hampshire family voices in the past has
done trainings for districts on
transition services for students who are
uh aging out of special education
post-secondary options post-secondary
planning we've done person- centered
planning we have done uh the right
question training in terms of helping
teams ask the right questions to get to
a resolve on something so it just really
depends on what the needs are of your
District um also different districts
depending on what's happening in their
district with initiatives like science
of reading for example um large school
district and and family training on what
is the science of reading how does that
work in your District um you know those
some sort of the district initiatives
that are happening that would impact
both families with students with
disabilities and families without and a
Fallout and then my other question was
around those smaller or there's 10
districts uh roughly that you mentioned
and also um those places where like doe
may already suppress data due to small
numbers or things like that so I I'm
curious to uh understand how this
specific piece of legislation might
impact that thank you for the question
um again I think the underlying premise
of this bill is to make sure that
parents of and students with
disabilities have a voice at the table
with some of the things that they see
that are of concern in their District if
there are parents in those tiny
districts that have those
concerns the way this bill reads there
has there would have to be a council at
every single District I don't know if
those families get incorporated into the
districts where they're students are
attending school perhaps or so I don't I
don't know how that would work um it's
just not addressed in the bill currently
if there's you know some amendments we'd
be happy to look at them and make sure
that that concern is addressed any other
questions say none thank you very much
that being the end I'm going to close
okay uh we'll move on to the next bill
on the uh schedule for day today which
is excuse me if if could if we could
have a little quiet in the in the
room thank you uh the next bill is a B
398 requiring Holocaust and genocide
studies in public schools to include the
impacts on people with
disabilities and uh the prime sponsor
cannot be here today so um I'll ask a
representative Lichfield to introduce
good morning representative Melissa
Lichfield representing brettwood
Danville and Fremont the prime sponsor
of this bill Lori Lori ball had reached
out to me last minute um she had some
unforeseen circumstances and she was not
able to make it today this bill has been
brought forward on behalf of a
constituent and she mentioned that the
constituent would be here today to
testify and they would be the one to
have the vast knowledge of this subject
thank you
um I do have one more card um for this
Dunham I I am the constituent by the way
um I'm Bonnie Donham and I'm from marac
New Hampshire I'm here in support of
this bill and um reason is because I
asked around and many New Hampshire
students are unaware of how people with
disabilities have been subjected to mass
killings Force sterilization denial of
education and medical treatment and
other acts intended to harm them as a
group in Nazi Germany people with
disabilities were the first group
targeted for
extermination um they started with
murdering children with disabilities and
based on their success um and and the
how they learned to be more efficient
with killing those children they moved
on to CH killing children and adults um
using poison gas and what they called
the T4 program German Parliament speaker
Norbert lammert said at an international
Holocaust Memorial Day celebration
ceremony I'm sorry um it became the
model for the mass murder that would
follow in the Nazi extermination camps
the Nazis murdered an estimated 275,000
people with disabilities but they are
considered to be the Holocaust forgotten
victims
in my written testimony I included a
horrifying story from a documentary
about one of the killing centers where
the workers celebrated um with beer wine
and cheese they essentially had a party
when the 10,000th person with a
disability was gassed to death I've also
included some examples with citations I
always I love citations um of other
attempts to harm or destroy people with
disabilities as a group um Ellie wiisel
wrote In his book Knight to forget the
dead would be akin to killing them a
second time people with disabilities who
were murdered during the Holocaust and
other genocides have been overlooked for
too long please recommend this bill
ought to pass so they are no longer
forgotten thank you thank you any
questions representative s thank you
very much and thank you for taking the
question um as one of the House
Representatives to the um State's
Commission on Holocaust and genocide
education I'm wondering if you at any
point reached out to the commission to
discuss this um for their input and
support I have not the um last time I
spoke out about it was when the State
Board of Education was going through the
that represent Bon thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I'm
just curious um do you know if they are
being excluded in the topic of
conversation right now as part of the
program from my understanding from
talking to students they're just silent
it they just don't they're
forgotten thank
you thank you uh any further questions
see none thank you very much thank you
and I believe that's the uh last card we
have for this
bill so I'll close the hearing on uh HB
398 and we will open the hearing on
House Bill 76 tracking special education
complaints
okay so this is um House Bill 76
um and the uh Prime sponsor um also was
running late uh on this so I'll ask
it all right um I'm Brian Morris here to
to bring up house bills 76 FN relative
to tracking special education complaints
um we have uh uh two people from the
Department who have um have filled in a
card that's the only other uh testimony
that I see um would uh attorney Fenton
and Rebecca fet like to come up that you
can come up jointly uh or uh
good morning I'm Rebecca fette Dana
Fenton just stepped out of the um room
quickly so she should be right back I am
the um administrator over the Bureau of
special education support at the
Department of Education um we did want
to um just point out a few things that
um might be of concern with the bill um
one of them was naming the school
district while we have lots of school
districts that are very small and have a
small number of students with
disabilities ities if we were to post
some of those districts it could be
considered personally identifiable
information um so it would be on line 28
it says that we would post the name of
the school district I think that's the
right
one and so that would be of concern for
some of those smaller districts um we
understand if it's a bigger District we
could definitely post them and we
currently do Post complaints they have
been um starting to post some of those
but our concern would be if it's a
really small District they only have
about five special ed students
um it might be personally identifiable
for for that District um the other other
concern was just that um turning around
a complaint within 30 days we would need
to redact everything and get everything
um make sure that there was no
personally identifiable information and
it just might be a tight turnaround time
if it's just 30 days but those were the
only two um things we do currently track
them through an Excel sheet and we also
do um Miss Fenton's office also does
post them online currently
thank you any further questions yes
representative Cornell Thank You chair
thank you for taking my question so do
you you think you do most of this
already um there are some data points
that we probably don't post I would have
to confirm with um attorney Fenton just
for the data points but um I think I we
do keep track of the date of the
complaint was filed the contact
information the respondents information
um I I don't believe we track the name
of the law firm currently um we do have
a summary of the allegations we do keep
track of the dates for the complaint
process and the status of updates
throughout the process and the outcome
of the complaint so we do all of those
things I think um the one thing that I'm
not sure that we keep track of is the
law firm for the school
district followup yes so is it not easy
to find or is there a is it easily
findable on the Department's website
it's just they just started posting them
within the last probably 3 to four
months okay thank you you're
welcome representative Bon thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm assuming that um this bill
probably has arisen from some of the U
um recommendations from the audit on the
uh just
U the process which I losing my my
thought here um so on to this I I see
that there these these probably came out
of the recommendations some of these
here but I'm just
questioning why would why would the law
firm be an important thing to track you
would have to um thank you for the
question represent bbon you would have
to ask the um sponsor of the bill I'm
I'm not exactly sure okay and just to
clarify you are concerned with some of
the Privacy implications by putting some
of that information out here y
specifically the smaller districts and
the district name yes thank you yep
R Mur uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so I just
wanted to be clear because on the top
portion where it um lays out sort of the
types of data that's that are being
tracked on line eight it does say the
complaintants contact information but
then further down below in section two
the complaintant information is not
there so is that being shared out the
actual name of the complaintant as I
read it no um it looks like just this
information starting on line 24 would be
what is shared out to the public thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much thank you uh attorney Fenton
comments do we have any you have a
question for
president indirectly Mr chair okay uh
once this bill is concluded yes i' like
the opportunity to speak directly to uh
through the chair to representative uh
Journey fent
as you had the issue I spoke with you
this
morning after this yes after this is she
done okay yes
right see no questions representative uh
excuse me attorney Fenton thank you
anyway um yes did you have a question I
did thank you sorry okay I'm sorry sorry
i000 hi
um so my question is the department has
U voiced some concerns uh with the with
the bill and do you share those concerns
and are there other concerns that you
bill well I I agree with the issues that
were identified I don't like the term um
having some concerns because as I have
explained previously the department is
here to provide technical assistance to
identify areas of concern um but we
don't support or oppose bills as you
well
know um I'm sure that uh my colleague
covered that currently the department
and special ed um special ed complaints
we do redact the decision letters and we
have posted those on our website that
was found in the audit last year and so
we have um taken steps to rectify that
audit finding and so I think currently
on our website you can find the letters
currently that have been issued in
2024 and
2023 and we anticipate that the letters
that were issued in 2022 will be on our
website uh as of mid-February so give or
take a couple of weeks there but we are
currently in the practice of in the
process rather of posting those those
letters
um and I'm happy to answer any technical
question questions as it relates to this
bill as currently
drafted representative Cornell thank you
and thank you for taking my question and
I know it's not your bill but would you
see any reason why the name of the law
firm
would provide any
thank you for the question um I think
that's probably a question better posed
to the sponsor however uh I would guess
and this is pure speculation which is
never a safe area to go into on public
testimony but I think the reality is
this there's this is a small state and
there are very few law firms that
represent school districts and there
could be people that find that
information just helpful in terms
of what districts are getting support
from from what uh Law Firm so I can see
why someone might be interested in that
information um a
anecdotally people will often ask the
department what law firm would you
recommend is there an attorney you would
recommend and so I think uh and to be
clear we do not provide that information
we are a state agency we cannot
recommend certain attorneys but I can
just tell you um as an attorney and as a
citizen and sometimes from the outside
looking in if you're not familiar with
lawyers it can be a little daunting so
knowing what firms represent what
districts I can see why someone might be
interested in that anything further than
that and again that's pure speculation
on my part um I would redirect your
question to the sponsor thank you but I
appreciate it thank you further
questions see none thank you very much
thank you
and we have um maybe a couple of minutes
until we chairman cordelli yeah I'm
sorry you had thank you always good
morning TR something just uh try to get
you a question you want prepared for
um yesterday I had two phone calls uh
from two different constituencies
dealing with Title One and with school
wheals both concerned with the the broad
brush Federal uh uh notice that came out
and asking was the um doe going to put
out advisories um they can't see again
I'm not suggesting you haven't done
anything I'm saying they don't have they
don't know where to go they're they're
confused and I'm sure they're not the
only uh entity that's confused I was
bringing up because I got the call
yesterday and you happen to be here
today representative cell suggested that
I ask you U since you represent the
partment you may have some information
for the deal for the constituency of all
of us to have this impact well thank you
for the question
um in terms of technical
advisories we are always willing as an
agency to put out air to put out
advisories to address areas of concern
that people are raising um I have not
heard nor have I received a directive to
put out a a technical advisory for that
particular area but obviously as a state
agency We Stand ready to provide that
information so I'm happy to have that
conversation with the commissioner and
see if if drafting a technical advisory
would be appropriate um as you know on
our website we have numerous technical
advisories about wide variety of
subjects so that is not an area that we
are uh we shy away from at all it is
however I will say a process so I always
just tell people technical advisories
takes take time typically I draft them
or someone else in the department drafts
them and then they go through a revision
process uh so it's unfortunately not
something that we can turn around in a
day or two but that is an area that we
take a lot of pride in um in issuing
those technical advisory so I'm happy to
have that
conversation thank follow thank you um
and maybe I use that as a two formal of
a a term and I appreciate the fact that
you people do those and get them out
there in the public uh but really just
something to the the districts out there
now who are I mean they just
significantly concerned is at least the
something to give me direction before
pending technical advisor because
they're concerned and nervous that's all
I appreciate that feedback I will
happily talk to the Deputy Commissioner
and commissioner about that and see what
if any information we can provide I see
that one of my colleagues has moved up I
don't know if that's in response to this
thank you by the way thank you excuse me
chairman are we still on the bill or no
CL theing on that I didn't hear the gav
I'm
sorry um Melissa white division director
for learner support New Hampshire
Department of Education we finally
received clarification from the US
Department of Education um regarding the
information that came out yesterday and
our commissioner submitted um uh an
informational piece an email that went
out to all of the school leaders to give
them background information and to
answer the questions so title funds um
that are formula funds Ida funds those
type of funds are not impacted by the
federal order that was placed yesterday
so it is just discretionary funds that
they're looking at putting a pause on
the thank you so much okay com forward
thank you chairman sure thank you um so
so our next bill uh
is House Bill 388 requiring local school
boards to issue public reports on
special education in their district and
the prime sponsor is here representative
Porcelli than thank you for coming this
Bill thank you chairman cordelli and
members of the education policy and
administrative Comm committee for
hearing my testimony today I am
representative Susan portelli Rockingham
District 19 Hampton Falls and Kensington
I sponsored HB 388 to requires school
district superintendents to provide
reports to Local School boards on
special education
statistics and make this information
available to the public on their School
District website and I'll say right from
the start no personally identifiable
information is included in this
bill for and it would not it would just
be illegal anyway for context in
1975 Congress passed a comprehensive law
protecting and improving the outcomes of
children and their families with
disabilities in 1990 the law was
reauthorized and changed to the
individuals with disabilities Education
Act or
idea the idea federal laws include
services that must be provided to
children with disabilities in elementary
and secondary school you may be familiar
with some of these Provisions such as
individual education programs or IEPs
free appropriate public education
requirements least restrictive
environment also known as mainstreaming
and the comprehensive assessment and
evaluation process these Federal
mandates are very expensive to
administer and the Ida legislation
originally proposed funding at
40% however Congress has
only appropriated a fraction of the
promised funding resulting in an
unfunded mandate and shifts the costs
for education of these students with
special needs to States and local
districts many school districts must
make difficult decisions regarding
hiring providers or eliminate uh
eliminating general education programs
last year over 26 New Hampshire Public
School Districts spent over
35% of their total school budget on
special education costs that included
instruction Services administrative
escalating legal costs and escalating
Transportation costs currently to
receive Ida federal grants the US
Department of Education requires that
each state compiles specific data and
submit specific reports for review on a
regular basis the New Hampshire
Department of Education Works
cooperatively with each School District
data what information is currently
collected and reported as required by
this bill for example the reporting that
is already in progress and would be um
available through this bill include
basic statistics about the number of
students with IEP in section 4 504 plans
and progress the number of special
education Personnel in the district and
total costs costs for contracted
Services costs for outof district
placements Transportation costs the
number of special education dispute
resolution cases and total revenue
received for special education so why is
this bill necessary well some school
school districts could do a good job in
providing this data at the local level
not all school districts provide this
important information about special
education to school boards and
taxpayers this Common Sense bill would
ensure uniformity and transparency about
special education expenditures that are
easily accessible to the
public you may ask will this bill
increase administrative burd
no because the reporting requirements
outlined in this bill are already
mandated by federal and state laws to
comply with the idea
Provisions while researching this bill I
had phone conversations with our New
Hampshire education commissioner
regarding overall State reporting
requirements I discussed reporting
details with the uh with several in the
uh special educ ation office and had
phone conversations with Washington DC
based Ida administers administrators to
discuss the Ida program and federal
reporting guidelines no issues or
concerns with the parameters of this
bill were raised during these
discussions and I did this because I am
not an expert in this area and I wanted
to make sure that the parameters of the
bill um were correct
as special education costs continue to
escalate access to current information
will be crucial for school boards and
taxpayers to accurately assess budget
and make difficult decisions therefore I
request ought to pass for this Common
Sense Bill thank you thank you and um
when we're finished if if you would pass
your written testimony up through the um
through the membership of course clerk
any questions for the sponsor
no represent bbon thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um as
you've already indicated you said the
this information is already being
collected and I believe posted on
unfortunately not all school districts
post this information I couldn't get it
for my school
district followup please followup um
but but you just said it was required
it's required at the to it's the
information is collected and required at
the state and federal level so this bill
would take that data and uh make it
available to school boards and more
importantly post it on a school district
website or have this information
accessible to taxpayers so that that's
where the disconnect is we have the data
and we're trying to make it more access
because for example in my school
data thank you we maray thank you Mr
chair and I think maybe this might be a
question for the Department perhaps then
following up on representative Bon's
question um so I don't know if if it's
not you then then let me know um I did I
I immediately asked whether or not this
this information is already reported to
the Department of Education and by any
one of new IE portals of of air are
available to be viewed by the districts
and also then
transferred by the districts to to their
information and reports that the
district communicates with one another
so that's question one and then uh with
regard it seems like you're creating an
additional re if I'm understanding
correctly a requirement for the district
to post this data and is there any
concern with um again those smaller
districts where suppressions or
identifiable information would
potentially be there because the the
size of the the sample size of those
available for 504s are IEP plant is
under 11 or something like that and this
bill is requiring that information to be
shared on the district website right
right there is no identifiable
information um in the bill there's no
identifiable information and although
the um information may be available on
various uh State websites the problem is
is it's just very difficult for
taxpayers to try to piece all of it
together so this is just a simple report
that is showing taxpayers school boards
you know where where this data a
snapshot of this data in a very simple
um EAS uh easy Toof find
format follow up thank you Mr share uh
my question isn't necessarily
identifiable information say my my
question is about the sample size of
individuals who who would receive
services are under that threshold and
then being required to be posted on the
district website regardless of what
other information may be redacted I'm
talking about sheer sample size of
participants so if I understand your
question I'll certainly defer um so if
it's a small school district and there's
two students with IEPs
the information would reflect the two
that the number two students not
anything specifically identifiable for
them so then we could look at you know
different um parameters to understand
what the cost of special education is
District represent bbon uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question on line 23 of first page you
are requesting the number of new special
education complaints and number 24 the
number of current alternative dispute
resolution cases uh going down again uh
you want legal costs um um I just
oftentimes in my district you're talking
about cases that do only involve one or
two students so even if you're not
personally identifying them
directly they're in the community and
you're actually putting that information
out there and it could cause a lot of
um disrupt I mean divisiveness in terms
of parents against parents in terms of
whose child is taking up all the money
for special ed
services do you I guess my question is
do you do you see it that way no of
course we're not trying to cause any um
concerns or issues within the district
but legal expenses are continuing to
escalate and that is a part of the
overall special education funding so for
example when we see our costs escalating
year-over-year and these these programs
are mandated at a federal and state
level um taxpayers and school boards
just need to understand where that
increased funding is is um required so
is it additional Services because we
have additional students that are
participating or is it these escalating
Leal fees that are um utilizing a lot of
these precious resources and I think
that is important information for you
know School boards and taxpayers to
balance thank you uh if I may ask a
clarification question so are you
suggesting that the legal fees that the
districts are seeing and the increased
ones are entirely from Special Services
students as opposed to contract
resolution disputes or negotiations or
other any of the Myriad of other areas
where School boards May reach out to
their attorneys for guidance such as if
there's a federal cut to their food
funding and needing to find guidance for
how to make sure that they can continue
to feed their children not not for this
specific bill it really is trying to
look at the totality of special
education um costs and of course
transportation and legal fees have
skyrocketed over the past few years so
it's to get a better clarification on
those
areas repesent Murray thank you Mr chair
for taking my question and thank you
again for taking my question I there are
census numbers change very frequently
and depending on the student body so I'm
a again concerned a little bit do or do
you share the same concern that I have
with potentially identifying a learner
or a new Community member uh by the
Cadence in which you are requesting this
information uh and and some of the ways
that you're asking it to be enumerated
such as quote new students to the
district if we I personally think that
it's information that is very important
to explain to taxpayers where they're
obviously property taxes are going to uh
pay for a lot of these services and we
have seen especially in my town a
dramatic increase in our property taxes
and we're trying to figure out you know
where is this additional spending and um
unfortunately one area that um doesn't
get we don't have a lot of data for is
in the growing area of special ed we
know the bottom line numbers that are
increased ing but I think it's important
for taxpayers to know what you know what
portion and what different um areas are
in that growth area so that we could you
know they can make decisions about how
to balance out their school budgets repr
Woodcock thank you chairman quelli good
morning thank you for bringing this
forward uh I let fall I may on
representative Bon's commentary on
sections three this information that's
public record um this public document
you're suggesting that the reason this
bill is here is because your
superintendent wouldn't give you that
information there are many different
school districts um in the state of New
Hampshire that don't provide this
information readily in one Consolidated
format to school districts and again
more uh importantly to the average
taxpayer that you know would just like
to see okay where you know what what is
the school spending and I just want to
be able to have that breakdown
understand it would be very difficult to
find some of the it was difficult for me
to find some of this information follow
just just clarification I think I heard
you saying your testimon because you
couldn't get it from your school
district as an example okay thank you
and just the last part if I may the the
other ones in hi j k whatever those
numbers are on those letters that is all
information that would be dialogue
during the school budget process and
your school board would be asking the
special a director what's his cost
what's that cost and and that's a public
meeting that people go to and then you
want on the budget so it's available it
just it seems to me that this bill is um
perhaps not necessary as it's just
duplicating what you could get uh at
your own school board by just asking was
that a question no yeah was no thank you
it wasn't it was a comment okay um see
no further uh thank you very much thank
you uh the next uh um uh person up is
Aubrey
Freeman
sorry Mr chairman committee members
Aubrey Friedman living Bridgewater I
speak in support of this bill
um as already been mentioned special ed
is extremely expensive it's like a and
getting bigger all the time it's like a
big black hole and um and so it's time
to actually
see you just see like a couple figures
on the like we're going through the
budget uh we have the deliberative
session this coming uh Saturday and so
one of the people who's really
interested in U asking a lot of
questions U I saw her list I'm leaving
the school district we broke away so I
can't even participate in it but I'm
still in part of the the district so I'm
interested anyway she sent a big long
list of questions to the superintendent
and there were a bunch of them
specifically about special ed and it's
true other than you just look at a
couple figures on a spreadsheet you're
not really getting much detail how many
teachers do we have devoted to this how
many students um you know you got to
know the specifics looking at a few
figures 1 million 1. 8 million it
doesn't really mean much other than it's
a big figure so she wrote this email to
the superintendent and him and the
business manager they mentioned we're
working on getting the answers to you
this is silly so this to me should be
automatically available to the P that's
what this bill is about it's all about
transparency they've got most of the
information right there um and they're
just uh so you answer her well then
somebody else might ask why not just
have it all up on the website or if you
don't want the the burden of collecting
all that information again put up the
reports that they already do which that
covers almost everything it doesn't
cover um I think it's h through J or
whatever it is about the uh
complaints uh
denials uh legal expense things like
that which there shouldn't be that much
uh but definitely the taxpayers would
want to know about and I actually heard
about a school district that spent more
in legal expense fighting a family that
wanted the services they spent more in
legal expense than the actual cost of
what the services would have been and I
think taxpayers would definitely want to
know about that so I don't think that
part of the things that it's asking for
that shouldn't be that much extra
information most most of it can be done
if they don't have time to collect it
all over again just uh those reports
that they file with the Department of
Education just have the superintendent
present them to the school board and
then the then there'll be public
information and that's good enough and
then you don't have interested uh
taxpayers that that want to get to the
bottom of things um emailing the
superintendent they have plenty of other
things to do so this should be just put
it up transparency is a good thing
uh what else did yeah it's um I I I say
it's basically a transparency Bill and U
making things
available they're not that they're
trying to hide things but people really
want to know
uh what are we spending and is it
actually accomplishing anything that's
part of the thing too is the results so
just spending an endless amount of money
even if you find out how your the
details of it are these making any
improvements or should we just continue
spend more and more what are the results
that's part of it too is are you
accomplishing anything so I think um you
really can't go wrong with more
transparency and that's why I support
the Bill thank you
questions seeing none thank you very
much for being here thank you uh Karen
Rosenberg
good morning I had to look at the clock
to see if it was still morning I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center where the
state's protection and advocacy system
for students and actually all
individuals who experience disability
and we do receive a lot of inquiries
from parents of students with
disabilities so I'm here to um testify
in opposition to this spill because I
have some very serious concerns about it
um two and in and and I don't know which
is most important so you'll either one
of them one I think it's patently
illegal I think it would violate federal
law because um as particularly in small
towns when you're looking at some of the
um data that would need to be released
it would inadvertently identify students
and we both under idea and furpa um
there are protections for student
confidentiality and prohibitions against
releasing records that would either
intentionally or unintentionally reveal
students identity so that is a big
concern um and I don't know that we want
to put our federal um idea money at risk
by passing a law that you know would
contradict what the Federal Law requires
in terms of protection protecting
confidentiality secondly um from a you
know putting the law aside even if it
wasn't a problem that we'd be violating
federal law I have con concerns about
the impact of the release of information
that could easily be um trained so that
a parent or someone in the community
could identify who's costing what and
we're our schools are established to
educate all children right children with
disabilities children without
disabilities and the way that our
funding system works which is imperfect
you all have another committee dealing
with that doesn't distinguish between um
you know what doesn't doesn't well it
hasn't looked at what it costs to
educate a particular child um with a
disability or scrutinize how much it
costs to identify them and in terms of
the federal funding mechanism we wish
the federal government contributed more
we the amount that New Hampshire
receives is based on a child count and I
think the think the thinking behind that
is is that well it doesn't all come out
in the wash it should all come out in
the wash but some students will um it'll
be less expensive and some it'll be more
but basically we're charged with
educating all students and ensuring that
all students have available to them a
free and appropriate public education
and I understand that it's difficult as
a taxpayer to look at your property tax
bill and your school Bill and see those
bills going up I'm a property owner I
see those bills um but I think we need
to look at you know how what what can we
do where to address education and
education funding in a way that um
recognizes Our obligation to educate
everyone and doesn't f divisiveness
among our neighbors our friends our kids
peers and their families so for all
those reasons I um highly hope that you
will recommend that this ought to be
determined and expedient to legislate
and I'm happy to answer any questions
you might have any
questions yes represent
Morris good rson Mor go ahead I just had
a question in relation to where on here
um would it breach federal law just so I
can kind of idea so the first thing to
know is that under um so you know that
under idea and under fura there are
protections against the disclosure of
per student identifying information
correct um and so and the way that
that's defined includes information that
would not just that would have like a
name and a student ID number but I'm
just reading from idea for for example a
list of personal characteristics or
other information that would make it
possible to identify the child with
reasonable certainty right so that's an
example under idea these are the kids
were talking about so now if you look at
the bill um things like I'm on
page one I guess we one so I'm looking
at this list from the quarterly report
the cost of contracted services within
the district by type of service and
number of students receiving such
contracted services so in a small town
it wouldn't be difficult to figure out
like if you see a certain bus going by
for example and you can see the kids in
the bus who's riding that bus um who are
the students the number of so there's
actually a transportation one right
after that um or you might know that a
student is blind and requires certain
interventions but how many blind
students are there going to be in a
district so if you got a report that
included you know services for the blind
from a particular you know Ider that's
known to serve blind children then you
would know how much it's costing and it
would identify that particular child um
same with you know students who are in
extended school year depending how big
the school is that could reveal um
enough information to know who the kids
are um so those are just a few examples
um and some of this information like the
aggregate information that is provided
to the Department of Education is
available under with a 91a request our
right to no law um one thing to consider
would be if the department of I'm sure
the Department of Education people are
going to throw daggers at me but since
they are please don't they have the you
know since they are the repository for
all this information and they have a
website that and they post a lot of data
already um perhaps that would be
something that they could post because
they're already posting a lot of data
around um the programs they operate and
school and you know measured success in
education assessments and things like
that so that might be a way to get that
information um I think information
around attorney's fees also might be
something not that the Department of
Education would have but that individual
districts could make available I mean
they might have to under our right to no
law thank you represent of
litfield thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so for me
transparency equals accountability
um and no one can have details due to
privacy not the Schoolboard not the
taxpayers my concern is if not this bill
then what what do you suggest that we do
because these folks I agree we educate
every child I have no problem with that
but these families are choosing to use
public tax dollars this is not private
insurance they're utilizing every single
other budget line the school board and
the public has an opportunity to go
through and I know as a school board
member there were times when I would
push back on budget lines for special
education and first of all people are
angry you're ostracized you're evil if
you question it no I'm just trying to do
right by that student and the taxpayer
sometimes there's something better that
we can do for that student that no one
is thinking of it just it's viewed as
this big black hole so what do you
suggest that we do just to make it
better and to make it transparent well I
think some things just may not be able
to be as transparent as you want them to
be and I'm sorry about that I think that
like it students records and students
services and individualized education
programs are just that and our Federal
Law requires that a lot of that
information about a student be kept
confidential but we do have laws that
Define what an adequate education is for
students what a free and appropriate
public education is for students with
disabilities and that they must be
educated in the least restrictive
environment according to their needs and
we have processes that are in place both
at the school district level where we
have the IEP teams which you're probably
familiar with and who go through a
process to determine what it is a
student needs to receive a free
appropriate public education we have um
opportunities for parents to dispute
that um and for schools um if there's
issues with what a student needs we have
um monitoring and oversight by our
Department of Education in terms of
whether students are getting their needs
met appropriately or not and schools are
facing Financial challenges right we
know this so there's not like a built-in
incentive for schools to try to spend
more money they need to operate within
their budgets and budget constraints so
I think there are a lot of factors that
can limit and do limit the amount of
money that expended for education for
students with disabilities and um and I
think that there are mechanisms in place
like Department of Education oversight
like the um you know this the the harsh
reality that schools have to operate
within budgets that's really tough and
so I know from our perspective as you
know the disability rights Center we end
up representing parents who feel that
their children are not getting enough
right and so um or that they're not
being educated in the least restrictive
environment and and it is and you know I
think schools do their best to make sure
they're providing what the student needs
within the you know their ability to do
this and I think that there but like I
said sometimes we more more often than
not the cases we get we feel that
there's not enough being um not enough
Services thank you representative Marie
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question is with
uh regard to page one uh lines 13 and 14
and I'm going to sort of um tie this
back to L or least restrictive
environment with respect to par uh
enumerate and naming the par
Professionals in number and specialist
by discipline um is it possible that by
um providing the least restrictive
environment and then reporting this data
we could be also identifying a
student um I don't know I suppose it is
possible although I know that
um as I so I I live in Manchester and I
know that it's it's really not very
difficult because this they publish a
list of all the state all the um city
employees on the website and all their
titles so it's really super easy to find
out like you could find out all of these
this information just on their website I
don't know that every city or town does
that but you could get that information
and I hadn't thought about whether it
would identify a student I guess if you
were doing it by school that might um
inadvertently do that follow up quickly
please
and my my other question then is um
least restrictive environment just
doesn't always necessarily mean lit
mainstream correct oh no no there's a
whole under um idea individuals with
disabilities Education Act there needs
to be a range of placements available so
um the least restrictive environment
would be to be in the general education
classroom with your peers with the
student PE all the time 100% of the time
and then um next might be that you're
you're pulled out our students pull out
like 20% of the time or a little over
20% of the time going down to you know
maybe the student requires um services
that are not you know that like a very
small setting that's just not available
in the school so there's they might need
a separate classroom for part of the
time it's really an in that's why
they're called individualized education
programs and so one students um right to
a least restrictive environment may not
be the same as others but New Hampshire
does a really good job actually at
making the L share of our students are
being educated in our Public
Schools represent selig thank you very
much and thank you for taking my
question just thinking about the process
of a student entering into special
education services and some capacity um
can you characterize the time that that
often takes for a family and and and the
difficulty um I'm just wondering how's
that related to our bill if we're saying
sorry um if we're saying that we're
going to identify the different costs
for all of these different
components if if there's a child with a
very with with a more complex learning
disability or a higher a harder to
diagnose disability they may require far
more extensive testing than a child who
has like you know a very easily
identifiable one so wouldn't those
things end up Co demonstrating different
costs that are going to go into here
that are going to further isolate and
distinguish the child
is there a quick
answer I I I think it's possible I don't
know I mean the process can be it it
really depends on the child the school
district I mean there are a lot of
factors there are evaluations that need
to happen there there's a lot that goes
into identifying a student as eligible
and identifying what their needs are um
yeah because we want to make sure that
we're not you know there there are
factors we don't want to over identify
children we don't want to identify them
as having the wrong disabil we want to
make sure that our programs are tailored
to meet their needs thank you quick
question
please would you believe that not going
to do any what what do you believe I'm
sorry that's not a proper question okay
question then how I don't know how to
word it I was in a district where there
was a special bus impacting 12 students
at
$93,000 a year going door too were
waking up the students and if they got
in the bus quickly to get to school on
time they would get
dunks and what do you mean Dunkin Donuts
and when when I when I had pushed back
on special education saying what what do
we do I'm sorry I don't see how that
applies to this it it was I was just
trying to get to the bottom of the
transparency because the push back was
they could end up at Crotched Mountain
if they're not getting to school on time
and being transparent okay than thank
you thank you very much for being here
Dunham thank you um I'm sorry if I'm
just combobulated I wasn't planning to
speak so I have I'm GNA have to turn my
paper around and around to read my my
chicken scratching um I am from Bonnie D
from marac New Hampshire and I am so
opposed to this bill um I was hoping
when I first read it the smidgeon of
hope that the purpose was to figure out
how special education for children with
disabilities could be improved how we
could identify some best practices what
was working and what wasn't working that
bubble was quickly burst um when the
words budget cost um came up way more
often than the words children and
students um one of the things was the
somebody said the budget um that this
information would allow the budget
committee to make difficult decisions
decisions like whether a child goes to a
residential placement whether they get
extended school year Services whether
they get special Transportation are not
made by the budget committee or the
school board they're made by the IEP
team based on the child's individualized
needs and then they're included in the
IEP and and other documents so it I kind
of had a flashback to when I heard from
a school governance Association that had
been newly formed and they provided a
list of questions which included how can
we get out of providing special
education what if we refuse federal
funds do we still have to educate them
how can one of the shouldn't a school
board member be on every IEP team um so
that they can make decisions and that's
not how it works and then it doesn't
work that way for a really good reason
um there are other problems with the
with the bill um
one is that it asks to have reports on
the number of students with 504 plans
making ad adequate progress towards
their
goals children on 504 plans don't have
goals that's what makes them different
from IEP it's one of the things um also
in terms of whether they're making
adequate progress even if they have an
IEP um by adequate progress the is the
meaning sufficient to achieve the goal
by the end of the year or because that's
the sufficiency statement that's requ
fired in every IEP progress report or
what exactly does it mean um the number
and cost of students placed outside of
the district really easy to to identify
kids in many school districts that way
um there in especially in small school
districts aren't a lot of them and then
when you get into dispute resolution
issues I spoke a couple of years ago to
a family who had a child in a wheelchair
in a small school district who was
filing complaint was planning to file a
complaint because the school had
redecorated the cafeteria and bought
tables that were not accessible for a
wheelchair when asked to change that
they said it would ruin the Aesthetics
of the cafeteria that was the only child
in a wheelchair in that little town if
if if someone said so a complaint was
filed about accessibility um for a child
in a wheelchair you know who that child
is and that family probably already goes
to budget committees having people
meetings in Schoolboard meetings having
in town meetings having people point to
them saying you're the reason our taxes
are so high any bill that would further
that is just unacceptable to me and I
hope would be unacceptable to you as
well in terms of um is this is spending
all this money accomplishing anything
the fact that children with disabilities
are graduating at pretty high numbers
here in New Hampshire are going out to
the world of employment competitive paid
employment
and are going on to postsecondary
education that's the data that will
answer that question and that is readily
available on the department of
education's website through the um
annual performance report that's it
thank you thank you oh
questions repent Murray thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question with regard to 504 plans um is
your understanding that most of them
revolve around Medical Health needs no
or excuse me and
was that so medical and health
exemptions not necessarily related to a
specific disability so sometimes a child
will have a 504 plan because it's to
provide equal access to programs and
activities so a child may have a health
plan Health needs that are addressed to
a 504 plan sometimes a child who has
attention deficit disorder just needs a
few accommodations so that they can have
that same opportunity they need
preferential seating they need to take
tests in quiet room um and so it's not
so much a medical issue it's an access
issue having a special bus for a child
who uses a wheelchair to get to school
because they can't get on the regular
bus that's something that would be in a
504 plan if that child didn't also need
special education services thank you
thank you for clarifying thank you um
thank you very much okay and we have one
more uh person uh Kristen
manami uh the office of special
education Advocate thank you for being
here
thank you good
morning um as representative cordelli
said I'm Kristen monani with the New
Hampshire Office of the advocate for
special education um I am testifying in
opposition to this bill and uh much of
what I would say would reiterate what
both um Miss Dunham and uh Miss
Rosenberg have already testified too so
I'll try not to repeat all of that
um I I think that cost of special
education are definitely a very Salient
issue unfortunately um our local
Education Agency representatives are are
feeling themselves constantly
constrained by this so I want to
emphasize that it it is not that this is
not on the minds of those in the school
district there are a lot of trade-offs
they're aware of that end up being made
in the budget between you know if we
have to go down this path and have these
additional costs for special ed it has
to come from somewhere but I think this
is a a question more appropriately dealt
with um even I think tomorrow there are
a couple of bills being heard on special
education costs um adequacy funding and
I hope to be here to talk specifically
to costs um this does definitively um
have numerous ways to identify students
um couple of examples um when we talk
about out placements there are fewer
than 400 students probably in that
category in the state um many of our
districts would have one or zero and um
I I was recently involved in a process
hearing and had the opportunity to find
out that some of our larger districts
have actually very small numbers of
outplay students so so 100% personal
identifiable and these are very high
costs so for a family um these are also
costs actually that do appear in line
items in the school district budgets um
so there are ways to get it information
but to to quarterly report on something
like that or to the types of service you
know again as has been said absolutely
personally identifiable and really
detrimental I think to family
um families are not necessarily choosing
ADT into using taxpayer dollars for
special education just like every other
family with a student you know we we
think of that being you know you use
public education families sometimes opt
out of using public education but
they're not opting into taxpayer dollars
or or you know even the concept of
choice to use taxpayer dollars for
special education I think has some
problematic elements to it um just for
the sake of understanding as well or or
Clarity um Miss Dunham touched on this a
bit but reporting on the number of
students making adequate progress toward
IEP
goals you know as the advocate for
special education I think um you know I
would love to see our superintendent
really focused on that but I want to be
clear on what that would entail um and I
don't know that the legislature you know
if the legislature feels it prudent to
do this I think that would be great but
really you know the only people with
that information on whether a student is
making adequate progress to the I goals
which is the standard would be um case
managers for every IEP team for every
student in a district so you would be
asking superintendents to quarterly have
those discussions with every case
manager which might be a good thing um I
I personally think our superintendents
and Schoolboard members need to um
sometimes know quite a bit more about
the special education in their districts
but I don't think this is um the way to
accomplish that uh and again seconding
much of what has already been said in
terms of the um person identifiable
nature and the inappropriateness of
focusing on costs because those costs
are simply compliance with Federal you
know and state laws and you know we need
to look separately in a different way at
cost of special education um not through
public disclosure because it's not a
taxpayer decision about whether or not
those costs get allocated that way and
with that I would be happy to take any
questions thank you very much
representative Morris thanks for taking
the question thanks for let me answer Mr
chair um so I just had a quick question
because I keep getting a range of
different numbers from various different
school districts as well as par
professionals so when it comes to
average cost for student with special
needs I've heard numbers anywhere
between 50,000 all the way up to 250,000
per year do you have like a is that kind
of accurate to say um so I'm going to
try to answer that somewhat specifically
and then also say I think um I am going
to try to answer that in in some of the
bills dealing with the adequacy funding
um that are also coming up but we have
multiple categories of students with
disability um that are reported I think
out of doe but um the vast majority of
our students we have about 30,000 plus
students in the state um with special
education
IEPs um the vast majority of those let's
call it above 25,000 are in the category
of lowest need so that 50,000 number Etc
would not be applicable there and again
that's the vast majority of students um
it is a number probably above any
adequacy funding currently then you have
another category which are your students
who are receiving you know a significant
number of services pulled out of the
regular education classroom category B
fewer than 5,000 students your category
is your highest cost and when you're
talking about numbers that go up you
know above 50 or 75,000 you're probably
talking about that category C and those
numbers can go very high right those
numbers can easily be 75 to
250,000 and higher um very small number
of students so it really to understand
it you have to get into the breakdown of
those categories of students that we
have um for cost analysis
thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much for being here today thank you
and uh I'm sure uh uh you'll be seeing
around tomorrow with those
bills
so that ends our morning hearings and um
we have until 1:30 which is our next
hearing so you have plenty of time to
lunch yes I'm going to go check the
you
e
um we're going to get started with our
first bill I just mention in case anyone
is here for our last bill um which is
571 uh the Constitution Day bill at
4:00
um um it it's is going to take a little
longer than expected so and the prime
sponsor is busy in another committee um
so what we will do is just introduce it
at 4:00 and recess it uh to a date uh
probably the week after
next um that way can all get home a
little earlier
also so
um representative kab were you going to
introduce this one great so this is
House Bill
677 requiring schools to maintain a
supply of EpiPen injectors for use in
the event of an emergency and uh
representative cutab welcome thank you
for having me here today for the record
my name is representative Caitlyn cab
representing Rockingham District 17 I'm
a co-sponsor of this bill unfortunately
the prime sponsor couldn't be here he's
out uh plowing plowing people out of the
snow so he regrettably couldn't make it
I hope that this bill will be a breath
of uh fresh air from the normal partisan
bills that this committee typically
um which committee does that happen
dreams um up until last year it was up
to um parents to provide the epinephrine
to the school districts and that law
last year enabled the districts to
provide a stock of EP epinephrine
however it didn't require them to this
bill is requiring them to because it is
a life-saving
it is a life-saving medication
and unfortunately in New Hampshire we
don't know how many kids have needed it
in New Hampshire schools this bill would
require the the tracking data we
currently require that if the districts
use it that they keep a report but
they're not required to send that report
anywhere nor post it anywhere so we just
simply don't have the data to to suggest
although this would provide us with that
data but when you look at National
averages about there's about six uses
per year per 100,000 pupils and so to
put that into perspective Massachusetts
does track the data and in one school
year recent school year it was uh 263
students that required the use of
epinephrine to treat anaphylaxis and of
those there were um 66 students that did
not have a prescription for epinephrine
and used the school's stock
epinephrine and um so about 25% of the
time when e is given there is no known
allergy and there are currently programs
available through both this is also
adding in the ability to use nephy spray
which is a
new product instead of having to use the
injector unfortunately right now it's
only available for probably with the
weight range it is probably for fifth
grade and above although there is from
my understanding um an emergency
application to allow that for younger
kiddos but it's not yet been approved um
so there are programs available that
actually offer this to the districts for
free and the districts only have to fill
out one form for the entire
District um with the medication provider
and they will give them a stock of up to
um they'll give them two up and effs per
age age group that they may need so you
might have an elementary school that
needs you know the the Junior and the
adult version and they'll give them both
for free as well as the nephy the nephy
also offers that as well so these can be
provided at Absolut no cost to the
districts and if a district doesn't have
a phys provider in there our state
physici has agreed to uh provide any
District that needs it a prescription so
there would be no no reason that this
would end up costing the district's any
money utilizing these programs and again
it is a life-saving medication and
unfortunately a lot of times that first
allergy happens the parents had no no
idea that it was going to happen so my
now four-year-old daughter about a year
ago
had some Nutella at my in-law's house
and I was in the Next Room over and
about a minute after she started eating
it I hear her go cedo my my throat is
really itchy and um of course I get up
and as as I walk out I see like all
around her face is red and my husband is
upstairs another level who's a physician
so I grab her and I'm like let's get
upstairs go see Daddy and by the time we
get up she's covered in Hive so it just
it happens so quickly and particularly
in districts that might not have EMS
that close by even in Windam like it's
it's kind of a drive you know you it
literally could be the difference
between life or death and so all
districts really should have this
medication available I'm happy to take
any questions uh thank you very much uh
represent Murray thank you Mr chair um
thank you for bringing this bill forward
as the parent of a child who has also
had to have EP an epinephrine injection
um done on them I empathize I'm curious
um to know whether or not there is any
possibility of getting adult doses
because often times my understanding is
even the junior dose even with little
guys is not necessarily enough so would
they have access to a varying range of
like the Junior and the regular dosing
regardless of age thank you for taking
thank you for the question um so this
would enable the the nurse to determine
the quantity and type that the school
should maintain so assuming that there
is most schools would probably have both
because you could technically also use
this for staff so even if you only had
kiddos that were under you know the
weight limit they I assume that they
would also have the adult dosage however
typically using something like you would
you the nurse would would likely be
guesstimating looking at the child if
they needed this one or that one but in
terms of giving a child that they knew
was under the weight limit for the adult
one they would probably give the
juvenile one and then they would give a
second dose if that was needed but I
don't think that this would allow them
to
just for liability reasons typically
unless your doctor gives you one that is
kind of you know using it off label the
label would say that the weight limit is
you know whatever it is and it' be up to
the discretion of the nurse to determine
in that moment which they have to
estimate weights for for many things in
in many other cases so I think they'd be
representative try thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question with the
aeds we've been trying to place them in
a place where they are easily accessible
not behind a locked door things like
that is there any reason that we should
maybe have to put this into this bill
too to be make it be
accessible so I that's a great question
so I actually did ask this of the
districts and I was the way it was
explained to me was that often times
they are in the nurse's office and not
usually locked they're not locked when
the nurse's office is open um and then
if the nurse has to leave the building
there are some districts that share
nurses across the different schools and
so they kind of go to do med passes when
that happens they have like a red bag
that's kind of their jump kit and they
stick that into the principal's office
so that it's available through there so
that at no time it's really the kids
couldn't accidentally get into it um but
that um it's not like left out on the
Shelf either I guess if that kind of
answers because I think with an AED you
can't if you're not in if you're not in
an abnormal Rhythm even if you were to
put that on to somebody it won't allow
you to shock the person but with this
there's nothing to prevent somebody from
using it if it was just in a box like
that I that's a follow up thank you I
think yes I think I understand that part
I'm just saying that even with qualified
user and a qualified recipient um it the
access is timely and um and we've been
seeing that some of these kind of things
are triggered outside and so with a with
a locked principal's office or a locked
school um it's just kind
of not not a great not accessible how
about that I agree with you completely I
think for the stock one you have to
probably leave it in at a centralized
location I know for my daughter it
actually says that it can't be in a lock
location and has to be with her like
accessible to her at all times so um
currently she's in preschool so when she
goes out onto preschool like onto the
playground they have to carry their jump
bag outside to the playground with her
and so I think the students their
Physicians could
write that it has to be with the student
and not in a locked nurse's office I I
would guess but for the stock one I'm
not sure how that would work because
they would have to maybe stock many
multiple of them if you are you asking
for the stock one or for the individual
student I asking for the stock one yeah
so depending on the size of the school I
would I'm not sure like are you are you
suggesting like if if the kids are
outside like also having one like in the
playground area we haven't gotten that
far with the aeds but it might be good
of us to consider them at the same time
because they're used in similar kind of
situations that makes sense
I having you know having multiple you
know especially if if there's a big
district and it takes a while to get
from the nurse's office you know to a
playground or whatnot
that that would be a reasonable option
and and the districts can this does
enable them to determine the quantity
that they need so they could stock
multiple in there that's that's a really
great Point that's a good point too
thank you thank you r s thank you and
thank you for taking my question I I
having had to administer an EpiPen to a
kindergartener when I was a teacher I
appreciate the value of this bill um I'm
curious where this committee will be
later I don't know if it's today or next
week um hearing bills that make it so
that School nurses can't prescribe uh
any medication or recommend any
medication how this bill would fit in
with those bills would whether they
would be contradict because they seem to
be contradictory bills that we're
hearing and how that matches up in terms
of Concepts if you have any idea I have
not reviewed those bills but now that
You' brought it to my attention I'll
definitely review and ensure that we
have an exception in there for this as
well as um for albuterol because I know
that those are the two medications in
this statute that we allow the nurses to
stock and so there I mean those are both
again life-saving medications that we
need to ensure that there's exceptions
for so thank you for bringing that to my
attention I will definitely check but
I'm not sure the answer to the question
off the top of my head follow thank you
and then the title of the pill specifies
epipens um which is a name brand which
tends to be rather expensive compared to
the um generic
versions the content of the bill doesn't
seem to specify that it has to be an
epip pen and I just wonder about um
finding the balance where I know you're
saying that currently there are programs
that would fund this but if at some
point it doesn't especially where they
expire after a certain number of months
and have to be replaced I know from
parents in my community they're
extremely expensive when you have to
replace them thank you for the question
so EpiPen is just as part a part of the
title but it's not at all a part of the
statute that would be implemented and
the statute piece does say epinephrine
Auto injectors and then it does further
Define that an epinephrine auto injector
also
includes um nasal spray um in the in in
part four
section yeah right on line 2022 so I
think that's just the ti unfortunately
sponsors co-sponsors don't get to choose
the titles with these OS kind of takes
the Liberty to put but the um statute
itself definitely does say it's epine
and auto injectors because that is a
really great point it they can be really
expensive by brand name so that wouldn't
that's kind of just for the bill
purposes but then once the statute gets
pen any further
questions yes represent Cornell Thank
you thank you for taking my question
does this have to be administered by a
nurse or can other people in the
building be trained to do it I I
wasn't clear that's a great question so
other other others that are trained in
this can also administer just like they
can for a kiddo that has an allergy and
I know you know sometimes people will
ask well if it's not prescribed to the
child How would how would the teacher
know that the child needs it well the
symptoms for an allergy are going to be
the same rather the child's diagnosed
with it or not so you need the teachers
that are trained in this need to be able
to identify if there is an emergent
situation and I had never seen an
allergy like that in my life and I was
able to quickly identify it it's very
obvious um so others that have been
trained can can do it it's just the
nurse that's that's deciding determining
the quantity of the medication but in
terms of giving it it would be um
anybody that was trained in it followup
yes follow do you know anything about
the training is it just a simple
training no no in representative dry
might know more about it but the Nurses
Association does have quite the training
on it um and I believe it's like a 2hour
training but I'll let representative dve
I am a an CPR instructor trainer yes um
anybody can give it to somebody who it's
prescribed to you can help them with
their medication and um since this is
now under a blanket authorization there
shouldn't be any problem with that if
the symptoms are there and um 911 an
emergency is always helpful and you can
get medical control for doing that
too thank you represent Murray and thank
you Mr chair and thank you thank you for
taking my question I do know I just want
to make sure as far as I'm aware every
anytime there is epinephrine used um the
child immediately goes to either the
emergency room or follows follows up
with a doctor so this is not like this
is a
life-saving uh instance where somebody
is trained some of these injectors also
will talk to you and tell you what to do
with them so um I just and there one
small point about them being stored
outside they're heat sensitive some of
them so wherever they would be I just
want to make sure that
um where it makes sense for them to be
where they are um so to that point I
guess I was what I was trying to ask was
um with regard to these um there's
there's usually a followup after the
incident correct with EMS or something
else yeah and so that would be that is
there is a piece you know in the statute
that says that it would obviously have
to be immediately reported to the nurse
um and then their training obviously
requires them to immediately cont
usually they'll contact EMS first and
then the parent or simultaneously if
there's two nurses in the in the office
and so I think that's covered under
their training which that New Hampshire
Nurses Association does have and it
actually does state in the bill that a
designated assisted Personnel shall be
identified um so that all so that as
many hours of the school day are covered
by at least one person so if the nurse
isn't going to be there that there is
somebody that's trained on this that's
always on
site great see no further questions
thank you very much for coming in for
this um I think we have one more card
Nancy
Beerman it has been a very busy medical
day today um Nancy Beerman um just to
let you know because I'm testifying
about something medical that I am on the
New Hampshire rare disease advisory
Council I'm speaking for myself and not
the council
and not for the council today sorry
thank you um I have a different uh I
first of all I approve of this bill um
but I have a point of view because I
have a child that needed an epip pen I
had um a sibling that has um had an epip
pen and I have been a teacher in the
classroom with a child um that had an
epip pen um so um the scariest of all of
them um wasn't my daughter it was the
child in the classroom because um all
she had to do is touch something and she
could go into an allergic reaction um
and for that parent um paying for the
epip pen or any kind of auto injector
was very expensive and she couldn't have
multiple ones most parents have one in
the school nurse's office and one at
home she can only afford one so we would
have to make sure that um we had a bag
that we literally passed back and forth
to each other each time so for that
parent um you know it was very
concerning the one day that oops we
forgot the bag and I had to ask my
administrator permission I'm like can I
go zip this home during my lunch break
to this poor child um um so they had it
um thankfully we never had to use it but
um that child's allergies were very very
severe um um as far as having a child
with it um it is um difficult to
um figure out exactly what you're
supposed to do with the upy pen um I got
maybe about 5 minutes training from the
doctor here's an epip pen read the
insert and good luck and hope you don't
ever have to use it um an EpiPen is a
stop Gap measure it's just supposed to
stop the allergic reaction until EMS can
arrive um and a lot of times if your EMS
is from far away and I used to be a
lifeguard and they taught us this too if
the EMS is far away you're going to have
to give double dose um if the reaction
starts occurring again until they can
get there
um there is also um another bill
h63 um that was heard in uh Health and
Human Services and it was in regards to
the um Auto injectors that were the
nasal spray so that was heard um on
included
um just so that you guys are all on the
same page um this bill allows authorized
entities includ entities including
schools camps and daycare facilities to
possess and administer epine and nasal
spray to treat
anaphylaxis um the law currently uh
permits FN fnf Administration through
utter injectors so they're um so you
might want to look into house bill
63 I was telling representa cordelli I'm
like there's another bill out there
trying to keep track of all these is is
absolutely crazy so um um but again um
we were fortunate our health insurance
company provided two epipens so uh my
daughter was um allowed to have one at
the nurse's office and we kept one at
home and so we didn't have to do the
whole traveling thing um I also have um
a relative that has severe allergies and
she was a school teacher herself and uh
she had to make sure she had one on and
um she actually had to use it one day um
while she was at school and her um
allergies are very um mysterious we
never know when she's going to react she
can react to foods and she can react to
smells and um so if there's an odor in
the air she can also go into anaphylaxis
and she's had two episodes of that and
the doctors can't figure it out but
thankfully we have the FIP pen and and
medical um people there immediately to
help her
so thank you questions represent
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you for taking my question as well
um I I the student that I taught the
smell of peanut butter two classrooms
away was sufficient to send them into
anaxa so I recognized the terror of that
we had to have a peanut free school and
among other things but um for people who
experience this level of allergic
reaction um or at least in your
experience of people who've had this
level of allergic reaction how quickly
do they go from fine to um anaphylaxis
which is you know blocking their ability
to breathe in in what you've seen and I
recognize you're not a medical expert
yeah no I have my mom degree um is what
I say when I talk to doctors
um it would depend if that person had
had that um trigger prior but sometimes
triggers can go from Z to 60 and nobody
knows why it's a mystery they don't know
why someone will get a be sting and be
fine and another person gets a beting
and need an an EP pen immediately and
another one will have just a mild
reaction um my daughter's um condition
um is called you toara and so sometimes
she can interact with something that's
cold touching drinking being out in the
air whatever sometimes she can go and
she won't have any kind of reaction and
then another time she'll be something
that I think is benign and not a problem
and she'll have a she'll have a big
reaction and I'm like why um it's the
human body is a mystery and they don't
know and um so you literally have and
the Mt expert can tell you you have 6
minutes um without if the throat is
closed and that person is not breathing
if six minutes till brain damage starts
to occur so it's you know dire to have
it but unfortunately you know and with
if you have the auto injectors um the
temperature thing is not going to be an
issue as much as the auto um the liquid
version of the epinephrine so yeah the
nasal spray it's because it's a powder
like substance so you're not going to
have so much of a temperature issue
concern with having it on site but more
and more people are having allergic
reactions every day
and can't explain it any further
questions no yep no thank you very much
done we'll uh close the hearing on um uh
bye
e
it's uh two
15 and the uh next bill is House Bill
532 um and uh as with this morning I
don't think that representative ball is
um um so um M representative Terry would
sorry you want to do rock paper scissors
or something or well thank you very much
representative Lichfield for
volunteering to introduce this bill well
you're welcome Mr
chairman so my name is Melissa Lichfield
representing Brentwood Fremont in
Danville this is House Bill 532 relative
to Alternative dispute resolution and
individual individualized education plan
team meeting facil itation the prime
sponsor representative ball was unable
to be here today due to unforeseen
circumstances we do have someone that is
here to
testify yes thank you thank
Dunham thank
you once again I am the constituent who
has for this um my name is Bonnie Dunham
and I live in marac New Hampshire I'm
here as a private citizen app parent um
this bill is pretty simple it just moves
IEP team facilitation from the list of
alternative dispute resolutions or ADR
um options that are in RSA 186
c23 comma Roman r i to its own new
section right below that this is
important because ADR procedures like
mediation probably the people are most
familiar with are subject to certain
requirements that cannot apply to a
facilitated IEP team meeting for example
alternative dispute resolution um
proceedings must be confidential and no
record can be kept of the proceedings
but a facilitated IEP team meeting is
just like any other IEP meeting it's a
regular IEP meeting but there's a
trained facilitator who's impartial and
helps the meeting run more smoothly um
and helps the parent and the school
district to work together to reach
agreement sometimes on issues that were
in dispute other times they're asked to
participate before there's a dispute to
help people to reach um reach agreement
more quickly and and easily using
effective collaboration and
communication it's a best practice IEP
team facilitation can help IEP teams to
reach agreement early in the process and
ultimately reduce the need for more
adversarial and almost always expensive
um adver um Regular dispute resolution
procedures like a due process hearing
any IEP team meeting whether there's a
facilitator there or not requires a
record of the proceeding including What
was decided the reasons for the decision
a list of the evaluations assessments
records or reports used as a basis in
making the decision any other options
that were considered and why they
weren't adopted um and any other
relevant factors this is not allowed
under the alternative dispute resolution
procedures those restrictions that are
listed in 186c um comma 23 Roman numeral
4 this issue was actually first
identified in
2015 um when Senate Bill 166 removed
facilitated IEP um Team meetings from
the um RSA 186 c23 where it had been
inserted a few years before um and in
the house calendar for the date when
that um hearing was was being voted on
the education committee re um explained
the reasoning behind their unanimous oop
pass recommendation writing regular IEP
team meetings are informal procedures
and during these meetings actions or
discussions leading to decisions are
recorded a facilitated IEP meeting has a
trained facilitator assisting in meeting
the pro and meeting procedure idea and
RSA 186c demand confidentiality and
preclude recordkeeping during these
meetings this bill will remove
facilitated IEP team meetings so they
it's they'll remove it from that section
um it won't be an alternative dispute
resolution option any longer but it will
still be a dispute resolution option
that the Department of Education will
make available to parents in school
districts who wish to utilize it in
order to um come to to come to agreement
more readily um and so it really is just
fixing a mistake and I thank you for
supporting it I'm just assuming you
will that seemed a little preemptive I
apologize thank you um any questions for
Miss
Dunham uh I just am wondering um in uh
c23 is room Roman numerals 2 3 4 Etc
right uh does any of that also apply to
mediation I'm just wondering there are
time frames Etc um are those different
because mediation has its own section uh
c24
so any alternative dispute resolution
proceedings like um mediation and
neutral conference is the other one
available in New Hampshire
are required to be confidential no
record they also whatever is um whatever
is discussed at the meeting can't be
used in a later proceeding with certain
exceptions things like that but then
they have another section on mediation
and another section on neutral
conference that get add some more uh
procedure specific
requirements does that answer that okay
I think so I just wanted to make sure
that nothing in Romans uh 2 three four
uh five um apply to um mediation um that
needs to be um adjusted also but you
know looking through it I don't see
offhand the word um
mediation um in those sections no it was
just facilitated IEP meetings was the
only problem there thank you thank you
um further
fet good afternoon representative
cordelli thank you um we
just she go like where'd you go um so we
had last year asked for this to be
placed back into the alternative dispute
resolution um language in 186 c24 um not
c24 c23 um this was part of our
legislative audit from last year that it
was not in rules that need to be placed
back in there we placed it here because
it is um recognized as an alternative
dispute resolution it is recognized by
the federal office of special education
programs as an alternative dispute
resolution and it is um when we work
with our TA provider Cadre it is also
recognized as an alternative dispute
resolution so while I I hear the
concerns that were expressed um it maybe
we need to look at it slightly
differently and and change some of the
language to address the concerns
regarding IEP facilitation but it is an
alternative dispute resolution and that
was why we placed it here in the last
legislative
session
questions representative Cornell thank
you and thank you for taking my question
but I got I just got confused are you
for it or against it um the department
does not go do for or against so um it
we just were explaining why we had
placed it here last year when we put it
through for legislation it had come in
our up in our audit so that was why we
placed it in this section it should be
with alternative dispute resolution but
if you wanted to look at changing
something possibly changing some of the
other language rather than moving it to
a completely separate
section represent try thank you and
thank you for taking my question if we
move it like this bill suggests will
your next audit turn up the same
problem that's a good question I'm not
sure represent SEL thank you and I
acknowledge I got a little Tangled Up in
the different components of of how you
were explaining things so this specific
process the department moved because of
an audit if I'm understanding correctly
and it's possible that there's some
concerns the the way it's currently
written in terms of privacy because of
the way mediation works or that we maybe
need to change the language I'm just
trying to understand sure I I got
confused so um last year we um went
through an a legislative audit for the
dispute resolution processes which are
under um attorney Fenton and in that
process it they told us that um IEP
facilitation which had been in rule um
had been taken out and we but we
continued to operate IEP facilitation
and they suggested that we put it back
into law so that it was we could
continue to operate it it's a very good
like it it is extremely helpful to
districts extremely helpful to parents
um it is being used more frequently as
we talk about it more it gets used more
frequently um and it and it is
considered an alternative dispute
resolution process I believe what um
Miss Dunham had shared was that some of
the language in 2 three 4 um in that
that same section do not apply to I IEP
facilitation um and only apply to the
other two pieces okay thank you very
much
sure representative Woodcock chairman
good afternoon good to see you um if my
assumption then based on what you're
saying now is
that given the bill as it presented you
you don't think it's best to supported
based on the audit and my second
assumption is if you don't then you're
talking alternative language would the
department be prepared to provide
used yeah so I am suggesting that it
stay under alternative dispute
resolution because it is an alternative
dispute resolution we had we had placed
it back in because of the audit but we
chose to place it back in that spot
because federally it's recognized as an
alternative dispute resolution if you
wanted to leave it there and are asking
if we would work on language then we
yes yes um for the questions resident
Murray thank you Mr chair so I just want
to double check and that I'm
understanding in rules there was a
change that removed this no in law it's
so this is no sorry sorry sorry yeah it
was placed in rules though it was
removed out of Statute and placed and
granted rule making Authority it was not
in any it was not in law or rule but it
was a practice that was being provided
to parents and so through the
legislative audit they said we needed to
put it into law and then we are
currently working on rules for it so it
will be in both thank you very much it
wasn't anywhere it had been and it was
taken out and then they said we needed
to so the first step was the law and
we're in the process of working on the
rul thank you for the clarification Yeah
question of the chair representative
Hall first thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so to be clear
could you just talk one more time about
how different it is than what Miss
Dunham talked about so how IEP
facilitation is different from the other
two processes the whole everything
you're saying and what she said her Comm
compared to you like just you know
compare otherwise I'd have her come back
up here tell us again um I believe the
concern that Miss Dunham expressed was
that the other pieces of the legislation
so at 186 c23
2345 um do not should not apply to IEP
facilitation I don't want to speak for
her but that they should not apply to
IEP facilitation because it a different
process and some of those things should
not apply to IEP facilitation which yes
it should not be conf IAL it is an it's
a regular IEP team meeting the only
suggestion we are saying is that it is
an alternative dispute resolution and
that was why we placed it in this piece
of the law and if we needed to rather
than create another whole section for
the same thing maybe consider changing
some of the language to address her
concerns regarding IEP
facilitation thank you okay yes of the
chair so would it be appropriate as a
committee to make a direction for the
rules process around this rather than
that I I would think that you know we
could work with the Department um if
section if Roman 2 3 and 4 do not apply
to
mediation um I think we could jointly
that would would uh would the department
be willing to work with us yes on y some
yeah would we be able to invite Miss
Dunham to participate in that meeting to
sure thank you yes represent I think I'm
still a little confused it's it's the
right thing but it's in the wrong place
so it's in the right place but some of
the pieces in that place do not apply to
IEP
facilitation so neutral conference
mediation and IEP facilitation are all
forms of alternative dispute resolution
they're all recognized as forms of
alternative dispute resolution however
in New Hampshire law as Miss D pointed
out section 234 all only apply to
neutral conference and mediation and so
she had wanted to move it out of here
and give it a separate section um I had
suggested that because it is an
alternative dispute resolution that it
stay here and we look consider changing
some of the other language to address
just going
back just going just going back to your
initial my initial question before then
F repr cordelli said so
basically the department would be
willing to create the additional caveat
or car out or so that we could make both
pieces happen that's why I asked you
right I think you know maybe we can uh
I'll work on a resolution on a simple
resolution to this and uh actually um
pass a
bill maybe
okay we'll see what happens in the exact
session
right great thank you very much um with
that uh no one else that I see for this
so we have a little bit of time until uh
room house bill
329 uh relative School District policies
on air
quality
um and then as I mentioned you know
we'll just have someone introduce 571
and uh be on our way and I'll reschedule
the
hearing this
La you not toed
yes
there
e
okay
um we are uh about ready for our next
bill which is House Bill
329 relative to school district policies
governing air quality and temperature
issues in schools and um representative
Sullivan is uh all set to go it looks
you representative Brian Sullivan um
representing Sullivan County uh District
1 which is the fine town of
Grantham
um the
um back in 1981 through 91 um I was
teaching in um uh the city of Berlin and
um it was little while ago um and I had
the pleasure of having a classroom that
uh faced the South um and um I have very
distinct Recollections of being in that
classroom when the temperatures really
started to sore and
um things have not gotten any better
since um HB 329 is a fairly simple bill
it U
modifies a current statute that deals
with um air quality in schools RSA 2 200
colon
48 and what it does is it adds air
temperature to the um uh air quality um
uh components that should be uh looked
at When developing School District
policy what what this requires a school
board to do is to Simply think about
ways of mitigating um high temperatures
and other air quality issues
um in schools um and in thinking about
it they should write it into their
policy um the more they can do to uh
mitigate um high temperatures um or low
temperatures in schools the more they
can do to make a uh environment that's
conducive to to learning it's well known
that as temperatures rise and get above
80 85 90 in the classroom um the uh the
learning declines rapidly so um this
does not require the school district to
do anything specific it simply requires
a school board to spend some time
thinking about the problems that are
created by um high temperatures in
classrooms um so with that um I submit
the bill and I'll take any questions
thank you uh questions representative
Terry uh thank you uh sir um I have a
recollection that a bill similar to this
one came before Commerce uh last session
were you involved with that and if so if
or you have any knowledge of that would
you explain uh to what extent this bill
is different than the one that we looked
at last term um there was a bill last
year um I'm somewhat familiar with it I
was not involved with it directly seem
very similar um but it it actually um
was far more specific with with with
regard to the uh various temperatures
where things would kick in and various
things would have to happen this one is
is far less specific and is simply as I
said I'm requiring the school board to
think about ways of mitigating um the uh
air temperature issues um without
necessarily um dictating exactly what
they have to do I think there's more
dictating in in the former Bill thank
you representative
litfield thank you and thank you for
taking you my
question can you please help me out on
page two on line
three um where well it starts on line
one the Department of Education shall
notify every Public School in NH how to
access the EPA tools for school's
program and shall require public schools
to implement the program exactly what
does that mean and how would that impact
things um is there a financial impact as
well yeah the Tools for Schools is um
a program that's been uh in place for
quite a long time and um it is uh I
believe it's and I believe someone
behind me could perhaps give more
information on this it's been a while
since I dealt with it um in fact I think
I'll defer the entire question if you
don't
mind further
questions see none thank you very much
representative
Damon
welcome
sorry thank you chair Celli and
committee good afternoon to everybody
for the record I'm state representative
hope Damon I serve the nine towns of
Sullivan District 8 I am a co-sponsor of
this bill and I would appreciate your
exploration and hopefully
support I think this is fairly simple
legislation to understand it requires
school districts to do three things
establish a policy governing air quality
and temperature issues in schools the
air quality part is probably already in
place because that's already in statute
uh secondly specify approaches to
preventing heat illness and third Define
an emergency response plan the policy
according to the proposed statute would
need to consider methods of minimizing
or eliminating poor indoor air quality
and temperature conditions a bill does
not require any structural improvements
in buildings or expense it's just a
first step to require districts to look
at what concerns there might be
regarding temperature and air quality
and what mitigating approaches might be
considered I think probably everybody
here has personally experienced the
challenges of unhealthy warm
temperatures distracting from our
concentration I know I did that in this
very broom last June when the sun was
pouring in and it was late afternoon and
sort of felt like the brain was
cooked similarly an unreasonably cold
environment is not compatible with
focusing on learning and we know that we
have many aging school buildings that
were not designed for ventilation for
the high temperatures that are
increasingly common at the beginning and
the end of our Academic Year in
September of 23 Stevens High School in
Claremont one of the community I
represent sent students home at midm
morning because the heat index in the
building was unsafely high for the third
day in a row I think it is likely that
if the heat index policy were in place
school would have been cancelled for the
day not unlike snow days thus saving the
difficulties of closing abruptly and
having students some of them lacking
transportation and other
challenges this bill will help schools
make plans
proactively this might partly answer
your question the USA sorry US EPA
indoor air quality Tools for Schools
action kit that's referenced on page two
is online you can look it up and find it
very very readily um and it is designed
it specifically says in the intro to
help inove indoor error problems
practically at little or no cost saving
with straightforward activities and
in-house um staff
I am not going to say that I read the
entire thing I've looked through it and
appreciated that there are in
fact I I would actually characterize
some of them as old-fashioned me
measures I think about my mom being very
conscious of you draw the shades or
blinds or whatever window covering you
have on the west side and the South Side
midafternoon and you open up windows at
night and let the cooler evening air
come in and I realized for security
we're not going to open the windows on
the ground floor of a school but for
instance Steven's High School is three
stories tall you probably could leave
the third floor windows open partly and
let cool air come in no cost no risk or
little so just it's not all that simple
but there are some simple measures that
we could kind of get more um focus
on and I also will just call out from
the um indoor air quality Tools for
Schools kit they specifically comment
that teachers can involve students and
teach them about environmental
principles when applying and they're
talking about applying things indoors
and out this bill is only about indoors
but I like that focus of saying well as
we explore what's going on in our school
in regards to temperature and air
quality let's make it a learning
opportunity for students as well and
then finally just to note it's not just
about Comfort it's about health
productivity and that we really should
be creating an environment in which kids
can do their best
questions see representative
dry thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking this question so we've been
looking at aeds and EP pens in the last
couple of um sessions and with an
emergency action plan for those kind of
things because there's medical
emergencies but they have tools
that we want to have available to use I
don't really recall any tools for heat
illness emergencies and an emergency
action plan so I'm wondering what that
would look
like thank you for the question it's an
excellent
question my thinking
about um prevention of heat illness went
along the lines of educating and
communicating about
hydration about layered or lighter
weight clothing lighter or heavier as
appropriate I frankly find it amazing
how
infrequently
people adjust their dress to the
different environment that they're in I
mean to me the same weighty jeans that
are comfortable in the middle of the
winter are not what I want to be wearing
in June um not that we by any means are
going to dictate to kids or staff what
they should wear but just a nudge hey
it's going to be really hot here
tomorrow you know you might think about
wearing shorts or a skirt and queuing
hydration especially with younger kids
as a dietitian I am very aware that
thirst is not
as um vigorous a sense as the other
senses we basically experience thirst
when we already should have gotten more
hydrated so that could be helpful to
that I'm sure there's much more for
preventing heat Illness but those are um
not tools in the sense of a tangible
item thank
you questions see none thank you very
much
Tuttle thank you Mr chair is it okay if
um Brian Hawkins is with me thank you um
so chairman uh cordelli members of one
of the House Education committees from
the record my name is Megan tutle I'm
president of Nea New Hampshire we
represent about 17,000 Educators across
New Hampshire and I do say Educators
because we represent teachers and any
number of the ESP the education support
professionals across um I'm an 18year
veteran e8th grade social studies
teacher and I do have three children in
the conquered School District in public
schools and this is all relevant to the
testimony I'm about to give I will um
submit my written testimony online
because there are some links to some
studies and if we did it in you know
paper format there would be almost a
book so that'll be submitted this
afternoon for you and you can click on
the links to the different studies um
I'll keep this short
basically you know as the um
representative Sullivan said before this
is the start of a conversation two years
ago September of 2023 is when this
really first started that week there was
that one week of school the temperatures
were horrific it was 90 plus every day
humidity it was it was awful
um nobody's learning in that environment
nobody's teaching in that environment
nobody's learning that uh conquered
actually had a couple other situations
that were going on at the same time the
water had uh high levels of lead so the
water bubblers and the schools weren't
working at the same time so it was kind
of this huge you know just perfect storm
of everything that was happening that
week that wasn't good so we're in full
329 sorry I'm just looking through this
um it wasn't just last year we had
instances this year as well where in the
beginning of the school year the
temperatures were reaching 80 859 de I
do want to point out you know as uh
representative Damon said nobody is
comfortable in those situations nobody's
comfortable in those temperatures hot or
cold last year I think it was in
September the same week the House and
Senate actually shut down because the
air conditioning broke so we weren't wen
at work here you weren't at work here um
if you were here in that uh that week
but the teachers the Educators support
staff students were all still in school
and that's just really not a good way um
for children to be learning teachers to
be in the schools
other states have um implemented and
enacted laws that are much more strict
than what this is asking for just a
policy other states uh New York is one
that is implemented where they actually
have some ranges of the temperature so
the classrooms have to be between
certain temperatures we're looking
really for this to start the
conversation and let the districts come
up with what their policy will be we do
know that every District's different we
know that even within one District
conquer for example some of the schools
are much newer some are older and we
know that a lot of the school buildings
in New Hampshire um they're aged and so
there's a lot of work that has to be
done for different reasons but the air
quality and the temperature really needs
um to be addressed this is it's it's
just not good um it's not just the heat
in runlet Middle School a few weeks ago
I had an email from one of my son's
teachers telling me that it was going to
be hot in his classroom they were fixing
the heat and so I thought okay you know
an email went out this is fine so I
picked up my son from school how was
school today I was asking questions and
he said oh you know so and so's class it
was really hot I said yeah we got the we
got the email we knew it was going to be
really hot because of the heat he said
yeah but then I went to the next
classroom it was 57 so even within one
build yeah 57 to sit and learn um and so
even taking layers off adding layers I
mean this was in the month of December
so this wasn't even in the beginning of
the school year from outside yes it was
something that was happening but the
temperature in the classroom was still
80 in one and 57 in another um in Berlin
last year the heat wasn't working in one
part of the high school and so they
blasted the Heat and then they just put
fans in to say let's try and get heat in
the other half of the building that
that's not the ideal way to learn in any
school it's not the ideal place to work
and if we think about students you know
their job is to go to school and learn
not a good environment for them um so
we're really looking to get this
starting to get this talked about um so
that we can make sure that you know any
student who's going to school does have
those ideal conditions and it's a
starting point right we're not looking
for those ex you had mentioned the bill
from last year um that was more strict
than this one um it did have some
parameters on it that we don't have in
this one so that's the between the two
um and I think this one you know I think
it's pretty simple to be honest um so
that's what I have I can take any
questions but I also have Brian Hawkins
here he's the government relations
director for any New Hampshire um to
either add anything or to answer
me the only thing I would add is just to
add to uh president T's response to
representative Terry's question which is
last year the uh Bill actually
specifically prescribed uh
fahrenheit
temperatures uh in the bill obviously
this does not um and so uh just just as
an example of uh this not being as
prescriptive as the bill that you saw
last year
so yes represent M thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking the question um so
on the last page where it talks about uh
of of the program Tools for Schools um
is there does that require action I mean
is it sounds like that would be
something that would make requirements
not just kind of think about but
actually do do you know what they'd have
do well so for example I think
representative Damon touched on this a
little bit I mean uh the the toolkit has
different um AIDS depending on what your
role in the school Community is so if
you're an administrator if you're a
classroom teacher um some of it is uh
related to the uh par excuse me um the
part of the current statute uh relative
to the investigation of air quality
that's done in each building um so a
good example I think in the in the tools
for schools program is what's the
checklist of things that you're going
through when you're looking specifically
at temperature and not just you know uh
General air quality um and so um and I
think as representative Sullivan said in
his um introduction of the bill um
having a deliberate approach to looking
at those things that won't necessarily
be a cost item to you know there there
are different uh approaches to that can
that can make significant impact on you
know the temperature in Building
represent David mentioned a few of them
shading um and and really having the
sort of proactive mitigation strategies
um which can go a long way to
avoiding
um these kinds of conditions short of
you know installing an air conditioning
system where there wasn't one before um
and and we're
uh we'd be happy to provide the
complete link to the toolkit to the
committee as as well so you can look at
all of the recommendations that they
have I ask a followup followup yes okay
so and I'm just looking it it's because
it's required that's big that's a big
word to me implementing it it it looks
like the department of Ed is then
responsible for making sure people know
it and then there's immunity if you did
a good faith effort in it is that
correct yes so this uh current statute
um uh I not sure why originally it was
just
encourage um because I think as
representative D said I think there's a
lot of common sense items in this um and
as we said school districts um are going
to be able to uh Implement these in in
different ways um so not all the the
toolkit plan is you must do this you
must do this you must do this is uh here
are the things that you need to uh uh
look at when you're considering um you
know uh areas areas of the building for
example there are going to be problem
you know problems for um extreme heat
one more yes okay and I just want to
make sure because we're writing this
down is if you're requiring it and the
department of Ed notifies them about it
is the Department of Ed responsible for
making sure that people are doing
this uh they uh as as I read it they are
responsible for
uh notifying them um and
uh I would think that there would have
to be a submission of the plan that the
school has in order to um uh confirm
that they are um are implementing the
the
plan represent Terry so with respect to
um last year's bill but also with
respect to this year's Bill and you've
describe the the differences between the
two um is is it the view of your your
members that this legislation would be
be helpful in the sense that it would uh
move forward concerns and uh goals that
they have that they
cannot um Advance at this time because
of certain constraints financial and and
otherwise and that that in effect they
need need a nudge let's say from U the
state by way of state law in order to be
able to make the schools a safer place
let me just give the rehearse back to
the example of the school I think it was
uh the representative Damon site in
Claremont where um the forecast no doubt
was was going to be a very very hot day
um the the students the teachers the
staff came in in the morning it it was
um virtually close to unbearable at that
time but so unbearable that they were
sent home uh at um at the noon time at
midday um is your sense that for example
in with with respect to that example
that the school
administrators I I don't know about the
teachers if if they had a vote but is it
your sense that they that they felt that
they had to do that but they would have
preferred not to do that and didn't have
the power to be able to say we're not
going to come in today because the
forecast is because I I can remember you
years about about uh want to go on the
way back machine that school was called
off because um it was flurrying in the
morning but the forecast was that by
midday there were going to be 4 to 6
inches of snow and more by time 3:00
rolled around so the administrators took
the made the decision we're not going to
have school today but now we have a
school that brings the staff and the
students in uh and and and they know
from the forecast that it's going to be
unbearable by midday and have to send
everybody home um so they've wasted half
a day they've lost half a day when it
probably would have been more prudent
for them to call off school but that
they felt that they needed to do that
anyway and now we need whereas in my day
the the superintendent had enough sense
to so we say make the decision we're not
going to have school today but now we
have administrators who are saying no we
need the state to help us do that and
the question is now we need the state to
help us do that uh thank you for the
question we state law
thank you for that yeah at the beginning
of the question you had asked about the
members and I can only speak about what
my members can tell me I can't speak for
the superintendent um I do think this is
going to help and the the questions
concerns pictures I'm getting from my
members is that even early in the
morning on some of those mornings the
temperature was already 70 something in
their classrooms and so we have pictures
from last year I have some pictures from
this year of classroom temperatures of
the the thermometers in the classrooms
so for my members yes I definitely think
this would help because um it would it
would be already set there would be
something that was already there for
them to know what would happen um and I
think that little nudge as you pushed as
you put it would definitely help um you
know one of the things that was brought
up last year in the testimony for this
for the bill last year was we'll just
have the teachers get fans okay I taught
18 years in the classroom and I bought
fans and it's still hot I mean at that
point when we're when we're dealing with
the temp I'm not just talking about a
regular hot day right 70 degrees is
still hot out but you can manage that a
little better if you put fans in the
morning blow the cold air in it's not as
bad when we're talking about 70
something in the morning before you even
get into the classroom and you try to
put the fans in all you're really doing
I apologize all you're really doing is
blowing that hot air around and it's not
doing anything so by the time eth period
comes around and again I taught eighth
grade so you have kids coming up after
gym class I mean you can imagine you hit
the second floor going up the stairs
there's a spot where the air just
becomes so thick so stifling you can't
even breathe in it and then you add in
all those children coming in from other
classes Etc um I do think that this bill
and then potential future ones will help
that and and my members do want this um
you know they they they want something
that is going to give them that you know
assurance that we're not going to be
having to work in 90degree classrooms
point repr Murray um thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I
just wanted to make sure should a distri
district already be exploring these
issues have gone down this road to sort
of develop these action plans that would
not this would not uh require them to
start at zero correct they could
acknowledge that they have already
proceeded so far or can you explain to
me how that might work if someone's
already down that path yeah thank you
for the question and um I don't if Brian
want yeah I can start it um my
understanding is yes they would continue
down what they're doing if it's not a
formalized policy then I think this
would just have them write it down into
a formal policy um and and you know the
good thing or what I like about the way
this is written is that we know that
there are schools who are already are
already looking at things we know that
there are schools that yeah some of the
classrooms do already have air
conditioning because they're either
facing a certain direction and they know
the Sun comes in it's a science lab they
need you know whatever it is um but this
would allow all the other ones that are
not doing that yet to make those plans
or to make those policies um and it does
let it be catered to that District in
that school within a district if they're
different yeah okay thank you
Woodcock thank you
chairman good afternoon afternoon maybe
we see you four as well
um my question deals with the the timing
um having been when I moved to New
Hampshire the person called
design uh and that design application
typically happened after school was out
the youngsters were gone in the summer
um when we had air quality issues uh
like a a surprising amount of faculty or
youngsters out of the building and C all
the same time we buy if the union
intervened we typically do a air quality
they' calling people but pretty much
based on the union saying you know soon
people are sick forget the kid soon
people are sick um and then by the time
they getting to be done already that
issue dissipated so I'm looking at this
as and I'm not suggesting this is bad
I'm suggesting that the the timing when
it's June and the teachers are gone the
students are gone the staff are gone the
kitchen's open everything's all nice and
clean the windows are open and we do our
design check so I just that's the the
reality of that is is what I find is is
I don't understand what we're doing here
I know represent Lad last year when
they're talking the building
construction of all the new pieces you
know that looking the forward and the
hearing applications all those things
but in our old buildings even new
building we have now um that that's the
part that that that concerns me that we
check the a when it's the perfect time
so I don't know if you find that your
school districts the districts you
worked in I just know when I was
designated that's when we did
annual yeah no thank you for the
question I I honestly don't know when
they did it in the school the two
schools that I worked at it wasn't
something that Administration came to
the teachers for anything for that I was
part of so
yeah yes representative Lichfield thank
you thank you for taking my question I'm
just trying to understand why we're I
think it's a worthy cause but working
from the top down at the local level has
this been presented um pretty frequently
to school boards and they're not
addressing it and or during contract
negotiations have the conditions adverse
conditions been brought up and not
addressed thank you for the question um
we're not always in favor of top down um
but for something like this I think it
almost has to be because if we leave it
um up to the local to do something or
not do something the chance is they
won't always do something um with
negotiations it's it would have to be
negotiated obviously right so it might
not end up going through and so the the
chance is greater that you're still
going to have some schools that are
having temperatures this high or that
low right because you know part of this
isn't just the the extreme temperature
of the the heat we're also talking about
the cold um and so that's why I do think
this one should be topped down just so
everywhere well and just just that as
I'm sure these are learning conditions
for students and so if we're if we're
talking about having you know this be a
com a component that every school
district looks at as far as having a
plan around these issues um it shouldn't
be just for Berlin it should be for
conquer and exer and all the towns in in
school districts of New Hampshire
any further questions see none thank you
very much thank you and we'll get this
um the links and the we'll submit it
online and we'll get they'll add that
link to the toolkit for you
representative dve thank you thank
Wilson uh good afternoon chairman
cordelli and members of the committee
for the record Becky Wilson of the New
Hampshire school boards Association um
we are opposed to this bill the way that
it is currently written um a similar
bill I think this was mentioned was
brought last year that did not move
forward we certainly appreciate the
changes that have been made to this
version of the bill and some of the
concerns that have been tried to be
addressed however we still have some
further concerns and would like to seek
out some clarification with this bill um
as stated in previous testimony about
this bill uh last session decisions
regarding temperature conditions and
school buildings whether it's too hot or
too cold are currently left to District
admin uh and board's best judgment uh we
don't see a need for a specific
Schoolboard policy to address this
concern we do see districts already
currently balancing multiple needs uh
student needs staff needs the current
conditions of their buildings these can
be difficult decisions and then while we
realize that bringing the kids to school
and then sending them home 2 hours later
you know in hindsight potentially was
not the best decision uh District
administration and school boards are
making the best decisions given the
information they have in those
situations there are some temperature um
issues that could come up in a school
that could not be predicted necessarily
simply just based off of the weather and
I think school boards and Local District
admin are having these
conversations um we also would like to
acknowledge the state of some of our
education spaces within our buildings
and our build their buildings themselves
um as you have here heard often in this
room building um needs are far and many
across the State Building Aid is at a
premium uh we have a lot of older
buildings some districts may not be able
to fund the changes that some of the
mandates in this bill seem like they
could require uh as it stands now we
already have districts that are making
adjustments to their day and to their
spaces based on uh the current
conditions of their buildings that they
may or may not be able to mitigate uh
with larger changes to the actual
construction of their buildings we do
have concerns about lines 11 to13 about
the heat illness prevention and
emergency response plan and mandating
training to School Employees on how to
carry out the plan we certainly want to
prioritize student staff and safety
however this is just another mandatory
training that's going to be put onto the
list of mandatory trainings that need to
be provided to all School staff uh the
way we read this bill it really would be
all staff not just Educators or
classroom teachers I'm not sure when
that training would need to occur it
could in mean that there would be more
professional development time that is
needed or contract um negotiations in
terms of adding time to teachers
schedules to be able to have this
training um and lastly the this last
section of the bill uh sections two um
in terms of encou moving from
encouraging to requiring public schools
to implement this um United States EPA
Tools for Schools this is a program
that's readily available online however
it's 98 pages and in all honesty I have
not read it completely but it is unclear
as to what if any costs would be
associated with the Department of Ed
requiring school districts to comply
with this um we would respectfully ask
that any costs that could occur as part
of this mandated participation be funded
by the state and not fall on the back of
uh local taxpayers as an unfunded
mandate I'm happy to take any questions
any
questions see none thank you very much
entry thank you Mr chairman I will uh
keep it very brief uh the hour and uh
you're all ready to go home uh Jerry FW
associate executive director nhsaa
um and I had not planned to speak but uh
when representative Terry invoked the
superintendent's name I just said Pro
probably better answer the question um
but thank you for the question although
it was indirect representative um but
the answer to answer to your question
the superintendants don't need a state
law to determine snow days and delayed
openings so uh I think that we dealt
with uh weather situations for a long
time with heat and cold and whatnot and
that it's not a perfect science and and
commend the uh introdu introduction of
this particular bill which is much less
prescriptive than last year we literally
had superintendant anticipating that
bill running around in classrooms with
thermometers trying to determine uh
whether they would have to be cancelling
school or not if that's a good use of a
superintendent's time it's one more
thing they do um but anyway uh you know
we do appreciate the the the
flexibilities uh of local districts to
be able to make these types of decisions
in the best interest of uh their
children their staffs and um you know
Hudson called off school several years
ago at the end of August because it was
too hot I think it demonstrates that it
can be done um and so I will conclude
with that thank you very much any
questions I see none thank you for uh
your
testimony and uh that will close the
hearing on uh House Bill
329 and um as I indicated earlier um
I'll Stick Around we have a bill that's
uh scheduled for
4:00 um on Constitution Day uh the prime
sponsor is um in the midst of a
testimony in rep's Hall and the bill is
going to be complicated due to a late uh
amendment that we just got this morning
so I will uh hear any testimony for
anyone who wants to stick around um and
then recess the bill uh to a later date
probably the week after
next so thank you very much if if you
want to leave now and that includes uh
huh
yeah
e
yeah right oh we heard 129 earlier in
the day I think May no 129 was what I
wor the blurb on last night oh that's
right that's what's in your brain yes
okay okay House Bill 571 would is there
anyone who would like to testify on that
bill seen no one um we do have an
amendment um that was passed out to the
committee and we will resched U we will
recess this hearing and reschedule it uh
probably for the week after after next
um so uh thank you for the hords uh
attending this hearing and um hope